Power were full.
Greg fits.
We were reading this bad
ass Abraham Lincoln quote.
It's a quarrel not at all.
No Man.
Resolve to make the most of himself
can spare time for personal contention.
And there's a lot more of the quote,
but you'll forget it by the
time towards the end of it. Um,
find that quote and listen to it or
read it rather. Where can I find it?
A Dane Cook's Instagram page.
I'm Dane headed a posted Dane has a few,
too many,
a inspirational post to my likings but
uh, I don't mind this one. It's very good.
This one's very good. Now I'm just
busting his balls. His aren't that bad.
They're a little odd. It's pictures
a little odd. He's, he's at,
he's in very good shape.
We're just talking about what a bad
motherfucker Abraham Lincoln was.
Yeah. I mean when he came up, literally
dirt poor and uh, found his way.
You know, one of these guys
that like was working nonstop.
I think he worked in a
pharmacy or something and uh,
12 hours a day and yet put himself
through law school by reading books.
Like the guy lived in the library,
he's one of the most well read presidents
of all time and he was a real fucking
intellectual, but he, he made his
way based on that quote. He can't,
he came in and he was attacked and he was
marginalized because all the guys were,
you know, they were set, the politicians,
they had the money and the position and
they just kept stripping them down and
he kept moving past it,
flowing past it.
And then think about what you
do with slavery. He had to,
he had to fucking go to war and you know,
basically know that half the country
wants to fucking kill you and you just,
you go right around that and you go note,
we got a bigger goal here.
If you ever had a conversation, one of
those, uh, southern deniers, but no,
that's not what the board was about,
man. The war was about economics. Okay.
The war was about economics and they,
but they usually don't
have the whole story. Like,
I don't know the whole story of what
the economic aspect of the civil war,
remember Matt down either. You know
what I mean? Like they just want to,
they just want to have that to say it.
Yeah. Matt Graham had a joke about that.
Remember Matt Graham? Is that, yeah,
they say it's about economics.
Yeah. You weren't paying the help.
Yeah. I mean it was a bad economics in
the sense that cotton was our fucking was
everything in this country. We're just
exporting cotton and without the slaves,
the business model didn't work.
Is that really what it was about? Is that
what the war was about or did it have,
wasn't there some other economic point
of contention? Wasn't there something?
I don't,
I don't even want to,
well, it was basically about state
states' rights versus federal rights.
And states should be able to decide
whether or not slavery was legal.
And then when they got out to the, um, uh,
what was the territory that they,
the state it was going to be, um,
you know, incorporated. And they were,
they were fighting whether or they
should be a Kansas, Nebraska Act.
Once they hit Kansas and Nebraska, that's
when they, that's when they had to, uh,
decide whether or not new states we're
going to be able to have slavery or not.
Oh, so really was all about slavery.
Yeah. Oh, 100%. Pretty much.
So whatever economic thing,
it's just like based on the economics
of you not being able to have slaves
anymore.
So it's not really an economic issue
was why do I think it was like something
about there was some issue about banking.
I probably should look it up, but uh,
well the banking I think came later.
I think that was with the Hamilton.
Alexander Hamilton created the
National Bank, you know, and uh,
that was not popular
in the southern states.
Just imagine that less than 200 years ago,
1865 was when slavery was
abolished. Right, right.
Stop thinking about that.
Right. It's so recent.
I know Grayson to God.
It's terrifying.
It's terrifying to think that we are
just now getting out of the muck of the
caveman life.
Barely pull her feet out of the muck.
Great. Any fucking years
ago. I mean, he got so crazy.
He's got black people today. They
can say like, I had a grandparent,
it was a sleigh ride,
so fucking abso-fucking-lutely.
I'm so fucking little way. There's
gotta be a few of those. I mean what,
how old would you be?
You were 1865 is 140 50 years.
Right, so that's like if they had a
kid when they're maybe not grandfather,
great grandparents,
other black people do have kids really
young. Yeah, I could generation is soft.
Rude.
Well that would be bad for it because
you really would want to have kids very
late.
He over there for the kid stay alive
long enough to to be alive to remember a
parent or grandparent. It probably,
maybe the grandparent might be possible.
40 40 and 40 right.
If you look at 120 if like a
40 is like about as old as men
usually have kids that would take you
up to 1900 then the next kid would take
you up to 1940 1940 yeah.
That's the kid.
Grandkid would be 1980
and that kid still alive.
Yeah, that's totally possible. Would
that be a great crank it one. One One?
Yeah.
Either way.
I was thinking on podcasts when you're,
when you're like going through like
everything I just said about slavery,
big chunk of it probably will be wrong
and like in a regular conversation that
would just slide by,
but people that can be listening to
this that like our fucking historians or
have Wikipedia.
Okay.
Yeah. And they're going to
annihilate me on Twitter.
Okay.
So I guess there were some issues.
There were some contrasting
economic issues.
The United States was still primarily
agricultural in the years before,
during and immediately
after the civil war.
About three quarters of the population
lived in rural areas including farms and
small towns.
Nevertheless,
the industrial revolution that it
hit England decades before gradually
established itself on the former colonies,
factories are built over
the north and south.
The vast majority of the
industrial manufacturing was
taking place in the north
south. I'd almost 25% of the
country's free population,
but only 10% of the country's capital.
In 1860 the north had five times the
number of factories is a south and over 10
times the number of factory
workers. Wow. So the norm,
it was really like a bunch of people
that were adopting or adapting rather to
this new way of living.
The industrial revolution engines
and cities and urbanization,
and then people that were really rural
and these are the people that had slaves.
The vast majority of them.
The country is really rural.
That's crazy.
And the slave trade was growing
just like wildfire. You know,
they just couldn't bring enough slaves
into the country. That's so crazy.
Yeah. I forget the statistics
on the number of slaves
versus the number of white
people,
but it was going to get,
it was going to get to where there
was going to be a revolution. Anyway,
here what it says, most southern
white families did not own slaves.
Only about 384,000 of the 1.6 million
did just stop and think about that for a
second.
Only one out of four,
but only 384,000 people owned slaves.
Like you're not taught, there's not that
many people alive back then. This is
1.6 million.
That's one out of four and
that's just in,
in the United States.
The people are doing this
all over the world, right?
I mean this is what they did back then
forever. I mean we are,
we're only now in the,
in the realm where we come down
on the countries itself, slavery,
you know the countries
like Kuwait and Qatar,
but this is a weird statistic.
The way they've got it framed,
only about 384,000 and a 1.6
million did upstairs only no biggie.
Whatever, whatever. No biggie.
Just more than a third of a million.
Yeah.
Hundreds of thousands of
people own people. You know,
it's barely just one out of four.
No big deal.
And you know, they probably owned the
average, probably owned at least three,
which means there was a one to one
ratio of slaves to white people.
They just didn't have the gun.
Let me throw this at you.
How many people in dogs?
Everybody?
What do you,
what number do you think that of all
the households that have done this,
10% 50% maybe it feels like,
right?
You got a dog, got a dog, you gotta go?
No, Jamie's a solo lone
wolf out there. He is.
The dog gets on top of the
roof in the house at night. Um,
I would say it's probably less than 50%.
I'd say Leicester.
Let's just take guests. You, you say 50
I bet you in rural areas it's higher if
you live in San Francisco on a studio
apartment.
What does it say there, Jamie? Pet
ownership. 67 million households had pets.
Yeah, but that could be like a turtle. I
want to know how many people have dogs?
62% include at least one pat.
So that could be dogs. Cats. Yeah.
Well that's the 1970s there's
not that many people back then.
Here we go. 70 to 80
million dogs. Wow. Okay.
That was a 37 to 40% of houses have dogs.
Yeah.
So I was right.
Bitch,
I want to see how right we were on all
that other bullshit. Kansas, Nebraska.
Act is probably the old that's
probably getting the 70s,
the 1970s I don't know.
I could've been totally wrong,
but it makes sense that it's like 40%
but it's not much different.
I mean,
where they're talking about like 25% is
that what they were saying? Had Slaves,
25% of the population or
somewhere in that neighborhood?
Well, 300 and something thousand
at 1.6 million. So one out of four,
half the number of people that have dogs,
right.
In relationship to the population.
That's madness. That's madness. I mean,
no wonder why black
people are still pissed
and they treat dogs better. Oh, in some
ways. Sure. You are you kidding me? You,
him dog sees a dog on TV.
The fucking a ASP sale today for sure.
Down. Yeah, for sure.
That's why the 12 years a slave
really hit me because you know the,
the thing that Terentino's did first a,
um, what was it called? Django did Django.
It was like, you know, there
was a comic book element to it.
So they were playing a big buts,
but 12 years a slave was like,
wow. Yeah. They used to fucking
beat and starve and raped them.
It wasn't just that they were owned.
It was a holocaust.
Yeah. It's, it's
terrifying. It's terrifying.
The human beings are capable of doing that
just a couple hundred years ago. Yeah.
Less.
You think we'd ever do it
again? Yes. I think, yeah, just
fell apart.
I think if things fell apart,
what I think is what we got now with
electricity and air conditioning and
civilization laws and rules and amp,
a general amount of prosperity,
like as bad as economy is,
is hard as it gets it is to get a job. For
a lot of folks, there's a lot going on.
There's a lot of shit
happening, right? If you,
you might be able to find your way into
this crazy mix of humanity that is a,
you know,
an urban center in Los Angeles
or Chicago or New York or this,
but there's a lot of shit happening,
a lot of shit happening,
but all that stuff needs electricity.
All that stuff needs it.
You have to have,
the infrastructure has to be in
place to get the people that food.
That has to be no stress at all.
You have to mitigate their stress
in as many ways as possible.
Give them activities to do so they burn
themselves out then and only then can
you have those kind of beautiful civil,
and we know that we're moving towards
these kind of beautiful civilizations
being everywhere that it's like slowly
but surely we're going to eradicate most
of the violence and the most of the
bullshit that that's involved in being a
person in less.
Some shit goes down like a super volcano
or an asteroid impact and there's just
nothing left.
Or video tapes of cop speeding black
people again and again and again
and again and again and again.
The other guy in Texas the other
day just see that the party. Yeah.
Fuck being a cop dude for,
how about that?
How about showing up at a pool party
with a bunch of drunk kids and you've got
to fucking wrangled them? Could, do you
remember when you were 17 or 18 or over?
The [inaudible] guys are, oh I don't
know how old the pool party people were.
But you know the young,
let's go any age between 18 to 30 and the
cops show up and you're hammered. Fuck.
I remember one time we used to drink up
at the bleachers behind the high school,
typical Norman Rockwell's scene.
And uh,
the cops used to come up and they'd have
to get out of their car and crossed the
football field and then we fucking
scattered into the woods by then.
But one time I waited down because it was
so like they came every night and they
went up and I went into the car and I took
the, uh, the hat. It's like a Cobb salad
cause you knew that they were
going to go up the hill. Clarius
Instagram today you can wear pictures,
make a dummy and put the hat on and
beat it. Put the hat over your face.
Look completely cover your face.
You're walking off into a sock while
you're looking at for your hat.
Here's The New York City
Police Department for you.
Whenever you'd fuck your
girlfriend with the hat on Polo Ba.
Yeah. You reenact the whole thing.
You get a siren. Pull her over.
Let me see your license and your vagina.
Do that badly tenant scene. Oh my gosh.
She sucks it. You have to suck
it to get out of the ticket.
Will does she like sucked her thumb,
right? Or did she suck his dump?
She didn't speak. She sucked his
thumb. Right. Was one of those right.
Imagine though Europe
board cop down south.
You got fucking nothing to do
all day and some daisy Duke,
you pull over some little daisy
Duke. She's scared. She can't chair.
She can't have her daddy find out she got
a ticket. She'll do anything. Come on.
It's happened for sure. Your wife's fat
cause you live down south to get fat.
Some of them stayed thin. It's a new day.
This is late. It's the only ones. No,
I don't think they get a lot of starchy
foods. Yeah. It's not their fault.
They fry everything. They fry
everything and uh, you know,
like doughnuts or kids like we, you
and I, when does that sound muted?
Donut donut recently.
Did you Krispy Kreme about,
we'll say a month ago. They have every
day. Yeah. You can't do that now.
I like a good blueberry muffin though.
I'll allow myself a blue
and I'm on the road.
I eat a blueberry muffin for breakfast.
The curry four days a week. It's so good.
It's so good. And they're really just
cake. Just cake. Tricking yourself.
You want to cook? Okay, so with
the oxidants in here, fresh fruit,
it the accident. It's a
cake. It's a breakfast cake.
It's all sharing shit entity.
I don't eat the bottom part.
I remember Frank Frank Cinderella,
he had a bit, he's like,
I'm losing weight and you
know you gotta be disciplined.
You've got to take it seriously.
When I take the top off that hog and does,
you know how there's always a
little bit ice cream stuck to it.
I throw that right out.
So not only is it funny that
there's barely any on there,
but that it implies that he's going to
finish because he doesn't need the top
anymore.
Frank Santos? No, Santa's
rally. Santos was the hypnotist.
Frank, Cinderella was a funny
guy. Oh, up to did that.
Nice run the sopranos. And
then, um, I don't know,
man. I know that a very few guys
had to delivery that motherfucker.
What a pro would, uh, in
control. Eloquent guy. Yeah.
It was a very powerful performer.
It's white.
It's always weird when you
don't hear about a guy.
I looked up what goes under would,
what is he up to?
I don't know.
Put on some weight that fucking the
grind of getting over that initial hump,
you know? So it's like one of
the hardest things for a comic.
The grind of getting over
that initial hump to two.
You become like a known national
act. We work alone. Right. You know,
did you read that book? Uh, I just
got turned on to that book by, um, uh,
Tom Dreesen.
It's called a,
it's about the comedy store back in the
70s. I'm going to get you a copy of this.
What's it called? Somebody brought
it up. Who brought those up?
Called don't make me jump or Jesus Christ
because it's about the guy who killed
himself during the con. The comedy.
Strike that. The laugh factory.
You know what the rudest thing I've ever
heard about that guy. What are barriers?
Like it wasn't really that good
jump.
Nobody cared if that got a job right.
He was just like making it all about
him. Right, right. Big Statement.
That's hilarious. And pay the comics.
The only think I didn't even work.
I'm dying up here. It's called. Oh yeah,
I've heard the name.
Oh,
I can't believe it's like literally from
day one it traces the beginnings of the
uh, comedy store all the way
through. And the crazy thing is,
here's how they describe it.
It's a room with a kind of down
and dirty comics got together.
There was a back hallway
where people were all talking,
hitting on women that were going
in and out of the bathroom.
Pod smoke everywhere.
I mean,
it is to a t from the 1970s to today.
Almost exactly the same.
I mean, that's incredible.
That's amazing. That's
amazing. Did you audition?
Yes. You did. Yes. Yeah. I didn't pass.
Here's what people don't understand.
Joe Rogan was a headliner with TV credits
who was headlining all the New York
clubs. You come out to La, you
want to work the comedy store.
W W what's the process?
I do five minutes of did five minutes
from Mitzi and she made me a non paid
regular. So what that means is you
get to go on at the end of the show,
which is what time after the last set
was 1230 that could have happened at any
time between 1230 the actual time it's
scheduled two one ish depending on who
shows up.
It could be one 30 I got on at one 30
many times and I would get on and not get
paid and just do the sets
after everybody was done.
And this is history. You were an
established headlining comedic.
I did it every night. I did it every
night. Yeah. I'd said I just want this.
Like I just felt like,
I just want her to know that I'm serious
about this and a lot of respect for her.
Totally. That police was Mecca man.
When we were starting out and stitches,
everybody would talk about the comedy
store in La with hushed whispers. Right.
It was more important to me to be a paid
regular than it was to be on a sitcom.
Yeah. I really didn't. The Sitcom
thing was great. I was like, oh great,
I've got money now. This
is awesome. I don't have to
worry about my bills anymore.
Yeah. But it wasn't what I was really
after. What it was really after.
It was a comedy store. I was like, I
gotta be a paid regular here. Right.
And so I did those a non paid regular
sets every fucking night until like three
or four months later. She sat down
and looked at me again and uh,
there's a dude named the Todd and he's
not around anymore. He got real sick.
He had a like a brain issue, like a tumor
or something like that, like real bat.
And he goes,
you get real sick.
It was really sad to watch because that
guy is the reason I got into the comedy
storm. Wait, what's his
name again? The Todd.
And he sat in there right next to Mitzi
and he just laughed really hard at
everything I did. And he told me, he
goes, dude, I hooked you up. He goes,
I sat next to Mitzi.
I told her you were brilliant and I
laughed at all your jokes. And he goes,
that's how you got to do it.
If you want to get people in that are
good next time when someone comes by,
like you gotta do that to them.
And I was like, you got it perfect.
That's what you gotta do once she likes
you. And once she, she loves you, you,
you become family.
Like
you can introduce her to
funny people. She'll, she'll
listen. But other than that,
let me, you could fucking, you
could just not catch her. You know,
you could just not be there in the night.
She wants to come in or her health was
slowly starting to fade at the time she
was still mobile and she would talk to
you and she was very lucid, you know,
in 94 when I first started, she
was very there. She was there.
She would look at you and talk
to you about comedy and you know,
knew what you were doing right.
And knew what you were doing
wrong and knew where to put you.
But as time went on, you know,
she came around less and less.
So it was harder and harder for the guys
that were trying to get seen. You know,
the guys who were trying to get past
now it became someone else besides Mitzi
did start pass, you know.
And that was like a,
and this would be like at 1230 on that
she would be looking at people are
shooting? No, no. He chewed up the
schedule. You on an open mic night. Okay.
I would go up every other night, every
night I could, I would go, you know when,
whenever I can get up. But I think he get
up every night cause like some nights,
like maybe Dane Damon Wayne's will
show up or these other people show up.
Well that was the wrap on the place. Cause
when I first came out I was, I was, uh,
I was always,
I don't know if I was intimidated or
indignant about having to audition for
Mitzi, but I sort of got in at the, uh,
the other clubs and then
I just never did it.
And part of the reason too is I had heard
that you could get bumped for an hour
or buy like a Wayne brother and stopping
in. And I was just like, you know what?
I just don't,
I didn't want to do that.
There's this thing that comedians really,
some comedians I should say really like
to do and that's like show up at a show
whenever they want and just go on stage.
That's what they do every night.
They show up and they go on stage because
it's a not for 10 minutes and they got
for fucking 45. Some of them do. Yeah.
It becomes this weird carte blanche,
like you're not even on the schedule
and you just make it all about you.
And you could do that because you made
it, you know, it's a, it's a very,
it really interesting.
I don't think there's any other business
in the entertainment business in the
world. It's quite like that.
Like I think if a band,
like if this band was playing,
uh,
in some local club and they're doing
their set and the black keys showed up and
they just wanted to go up there,
well you can do it after the show's over.
You show,
you know,
I mean I would imagine I'm just
talking about like we'll do a club,
he'll call them on Wednesday and say I
want to do this weekend and I'll pay.
He pays out the other acts on the shell.
They can only tweet it and then
it sells out in a couple hours.
But like why not?
Like my whole thing is if
you stop by at nine 20,
right in the tits spot of the shell and
you do 45 like when did it occur to you
that you might stop by?
What about,
did it happen at noon where you could
have called in and accommodated people a
little bit or did you have to just shell
up right before you want to go on the
alarm of on walk in and be
the next act on the shelf?
Some people love doing that.
It's not their favorite thing.
They don't want to even call in for
spots. That's, they just want to do right
at. Some guys will do it for
10 minutes, which is great.
Louis C K wants to stop in on my
show that I'm on and do 10 minutes.
That's fucking great at Jack's.
The crowd up,
it makes it a special night for them and
it's good for the club so I don't care,
but do 10 minutes.
Yeah. Um, it's just,
I think there's the one benefit in it
for them is that if you become like super
famous, like fuel, like Louis Ck,
standup comedy famous and you,
uh, you have shows places you're
going to get your crowd all the time.
Whereas if you just show up randomly
and no one knows you're going to be at,
that's true.
That's the only time you're going to
get an impartial crowd or you know,
semi impartial crowd. Yeah,
no, that's a good point.
I think that's very critical for a
lot of guys in the development process
because that's one of the things that
Steve Martin and said we'd like killed him
and made him not want
to do standup anymore.
So he got so big when he was in
that let's get small error that era,
like he was a monster. Lincoln,
maybe people don't know like you,
you need to go and uh,
listen to, let's get small.
I'm sure it's probably available online
somewhere, but it's an amazing album.
When Steve Martin was just on fire,
he was so good.
He was so funny and so silly
and so specific. He had a voice. Yeah.
That you couldn't really pinpoint
what exactly his character was.
It was just like this kind of dumb,
egotistical guy.
But he also had really absurd, almost
Steven. Right. Kind of thoughts, dude.
He was amazing. Yeah. He really was.
How amazing he was.
That was his best work by far.
And it almost hurts my feelings that,
I mean,
he was a great actor and
he did some great movies,
but it almost hurts my feelings that he,
he didn't stick with standup.
See, I don't think he's a
great actor. I, you know, and,
and I have the utmost respect for him
and I do think he probably affected me as
much as any other comic.
When I first started out,
I saw him live and memorized all
his albums, but I don't know,
I always found is acting to
be a little self conscious,
little stiff when I've seen him in some
really good things I'd have to go over
is I am db to figure out
what the fuck they were.
But nothing was just, we both agree to
that nothing is good as the stem. No Way.
It was so good. Yeah. He
was great in the gym. Yeah.
It's really good in the truck.
But that was the young Steve Martin
there was still doing standup and he had
those, we had those little indie
films he made before that there was a,
there was a dead men don't
wear plaid. Oh yeah. Um,
what was the other one then?
Don't wear plaid watches,
I think shot in black and white
and they use clips of old,
like filmed the lard detective movies.
I'm like the fifties
Damn Lawrence.
That guy was a fucking wizard
man. Yeah, he really was good.
Who was really good when he was on,
when he was in his prime. It was just,
I was a little
kid at the time and my parents were in
a comedy albums like my parents had the
Cosby I think is, is it
himself? Bill Cosby himself.
That was a big record for
him a long time ago. Yeah.
Yeah. Which has first
one was, yeah. Himself.
That was the first one I think so what?
Whatever it was,
it was like a second one was who would
do with the Noah's Ark fell asleep with
bill Cosby. That's a different
one. Nap Time with bill costs.
You, you look tired, Bill Cosby.
Hey,
has there ever been a public figure that
has gone from being the most one of the
most loved of all time?
Like Bill Cosby,
pre rape accusations was one
of the most jazz guys. Yeah.
But Michael Jackson,
it was never definitive. It was always
weird. Yeah. It was always weird.
Bill Cosby was like the voice
of like he was moral. Yeah.
He was like this sweet grandpa type
character that didn't want you using bad
language. Like how, how crazy.
He was probably a guy. He's
gotten more of those. He,
I'm honorary doctorates.
Yeah,
he's the fee I honorary doctorate guy.
He definitely has at least one of those,
cause I know they were,
he was asking people to
refer to him as doctor Cosby.
I always thought he was
just fucking around. Now
[inaudible] his ego is out of control.
I'm,
I know this guy that used to do all of
his, uh, his day to day. Yeah. He's like,
he was the assistant to the agent
who had to actually deal with it.
That dude had three full time houses.
One in Colorado, one in New York,
one in La.
Each one had a chef and a
maid and a driver all on call.
Like literally on call because he had his
own jet and he would do a Gig in Saint
Louis and none of the three
houses knew which house,
who's going to go to that night.
He would just fucking go and
you had to be ready. Whoa. Yeah,
food stocked. How's clean? Ready
to roll. That's pretty bad.
Yeah. I'm not saying that
whatever live like that.
That's a lot of overhead
be a lot of time,
a lot overhead
kind of houses he's living in
to like Jesus Christ. Right.
But I bet he made a shit ton of money on
the Cosby show cause that was his show.
He owned that.
She owned it and he also owns fat Albert
right member and he don't, you don't,
you can't even find that anymore.
Which I find fat Albert,
where the fuck is fat Albert? You
never hear about that. Anyway,
he, he didn't fight. He bought
the little rascals, didn't he?
Or was that a rumor? Was that snapped? I
think that might fill in those knowing.
It's like you got to look at the guys
touring schedule. He is never let up.
He has done 200 nights a year.
Yeah.
Where he's making what
does cause we could for,
I mean in his prime he was
good for a hundred grand.
At least a hundred grand a night.
Right. It at least two shows on a week.
He would be in Phoenix one night,
Tucson, the next flying to each place.
Oh, you Snopes it right when I was
Snopes in it. Okay. It's false. Bill.
Didn't we cover this before?
I feel like we covered this on an earlier
podcast cause I was remembering it.
I was like, man, I feel like
that's been Snoop's did. Okay.
Yeah, it's false. Totally.
Okay.
I was aware.
Are those fucking videos then?
Where are they? Because they're
weird. They're weird. They're weird.
They're a really good slice
of a America. Yeah. Yeah.
I mean it was a fucking, these
were like ghetto kids. Yeah. Yeah.
We're the likable black ghetto kids.
So bill Cosby never owned any
part of the little rascals.
It never aren't any part of
the rights to were rascals.
Yeah.
Where the fuck are those videos?
Then they should release those.
Those things are time capsules.
Like you're,
you're looking into a different
style of human. Right. You know,
like my kids got into Popeye recently.
I've no shit buy form. You really?
Yeah. The really old ones from the 30
days. Some of them sponsored by the NRA,
by the way. Yes. The beginning of Popeye.
There's a fucking NRA logo.
No National Rifle Association Helps
Sponsor Popeye 1930s that's hilarious.
It is a different era. And Mike, we
were watched New Orleans. Jesus Christ.
It's so fucking violent.
Like it's all violence.
It's all everyone's trying to steal.
Blew those. Always trying to rape.
Blue is always trying to rape olive Oyl
and Popeye has to beat the fuck out of
them. This is, this is every day.
Tell me down below.
He's getting fucking hit in the
head with flower pots and shit.
[inaudible] sailors. Yeah. Is
the sailor world. Yeah, man.
Rapey I've watched in olive
oil getting raped. Holly Shit.
Well she's like rope. It's weird. Like
you can't hold onto her. She's like,
she moves like a snake. Like she
doesn't have any articulating joints.
Everything just moves. It's like
that style of cartoon was so weird.
You know, everybody's arms were like
ropes, like especially olive oil.
There was no like joint,
it wasn't like they bent at the knee.
Nothing moved all over the place.
Yeah, she was super anorexic.
Yeah.
The ogling of olive oil.
What do you uh, what do this,
that I don't think that's
the original either.
That seems like much more a recent stuff.
The really old stuff is the black
and white stuff and that's a,
a lot of the stuff that I've been
watching, it's real weird because um,
the way they too
is like,
it's real hand animated so like it's
not very smooth and they bounce back and
forth. Like while they don't
just stand there and talk,
they have like a little
dance that they do.
They lean back and forth and back and
forth and back and forth to create a sense
of movement. I don't know why they're
doing it, but it's interesting to watch.
It's like it's such a unique and specific
style of cartooning and you realize
like,
well this is the original style films
and only been around for a few decades
when they are doing this. Like
this is really, really, really,
yeah. The early Disney stuff, it looks
like they took a a a notebook here.
When you write the pictures on each
page, that's what it looked like. Yeah.
That's probably why he
was bouncing around.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure. Yeah. I mean it
was just much less specific. I mean,
I don't even know how many people they
had working on those things, but how long
must've taken to make one of
those cartoons, man. Fuck that.
The cells are worth a lot of money.
Oh,
first cells of Disney
probably worth millions.
Probably millions, right?
Yeah. I got a Simpson Sal.
They're not that hard to get
really go Simpson. So yeah,
it will because every episode is
made up a fucking thousands of cells.
So they sell all of them. I, Sam Simon
gave me one. Oh Wow. That's cool.
Somebody gave me a self in the American
Werewolf in London. Yeah. Yeah. Oh,
that's cool. That's pretty dope.
Just to have a piece of that.
My son is, uh, he's getting
into, he wants my list of movie,
so we watched Scarface together two
nights ago. Really? That was bad ass.
Cause I watched that fucking movie every
Friday night for probably a year and a
half. Me and my buddies
would get together, get high,
drink beer and watch
Scarface and just recite it.
What was that episode of
the, um, Larry David's show?
Curb your enthusiasm or he had a
rapper that he was hanging around with,
had a wonky eye. What was the evil
eye? The guy was crazy. I killed her.
That's it. And that's all he
did is he watched Scarface,
his car face playing
above his bed, 24, seven.
It's huge. And the rap world, you know,
Scarface is it, what's a bad guy? Was
the winner. He was the hero. All right.
What other movie ever has there been?
We're a coke smuggling immigrant who was
a prisoner in Cuba and murderer is the
hero of the movie.
Well the Godfather, but that was, uh, you
know, and that's the same thing. I mean,
these, these rappers are into the
Godfather, Goodfellas, Scarface,
anything gang related. And these are
all the movies and my son wants to see,
because he listens to this hardcore rap.
Like what the fuck?
And I don't want to be the guy who goes
that music, you know? I was just like,
all right.
I guess that's what he's listening to.
Nothing I can do about it is the young
white point. He wants to be legit.
What are you gonna do? Right?
Rough. It's rough faction man.
Out of his friends are black. None of his
friends now, a lot of his friends are,
a lot of his friends are, and it's, his
first girlfriend was black. Oh Shit. Yeah.
Oh, so she was cute. Is um,
does your kid want to be a rapper?
Like a Tom Hanks' son that
wants to be a rapper? Tom Hanks.
He shows the pistols in his
Instagram. Yeah. It's like, dude,
your dad's Forrest Gump.
Okay. Just shut the fuck up.
Don't tell me about the hard life in Bel
Air that you led. Shh. No, you can't.
There's certain shit you can,
you can't be a gangster rapper
when you're Tom Hanks is son. Yeah.
And trying to prove yourself a gangster
rapper. You're gonna wind up in jail.
You better be careful.
Yeah.
He better not try because it's going to
overcompensate. Exactly. Well, what are,
what are will Smith's kids
like? I mean they wrap, right?
Well this in one of his kids like believe
that the world is an illusion or some
shit like he sounds about right.
He says ridiculous shit on his Twitter
page that people like a retweet all the
time and go l o l w u t and shit,
that kind of shit.
Right Jayden?
He just deleted his Twitter yesterday
though because people being mean to him
and the kids got, he's got a creative
imagination and I'm out apparently, um,
you know, from talking to people that
like worked with will Smith and they said,
that guy's a genius. Said he just reads
constantly. It's like stacks of books.
He flies around with everywhere he goes.
It's constantly reading is
the consummate gentlemen.
Like I never heard a bad word about that
guy. Now. Super, super, Super Nice Guy.
Apparently this one dude,
I know Johnny Mack,
he's this real fucking gangster.
He was in jail for a bunch of years,
but he's a writer.
He writes on,
he wrote on Martin and he wrote
on fresh prince and he said that,
uh, they hired him because they wanted
fresh prince to have a little bit more
legitimacy in the black world.
So they hired he just fucking gangster
to write on the show Johnny back.
And so he comes in and, uh,
I, I forget what happened,
but like a will Smith,
Kate kept shitting on him cause he was,
he was the cool guy and I think he maybe
felt a little threatened by him and uh,
he, he did something and Johnny
Mac just fucking picked him up,
put him against the wall by his neck and
scare the shit out of him and he never
said anything to him again.
Wow. Is that true though?
According to Johnny Mac. Hmm.
Who's Johnny? My character.
Great Dude. Love Johnny
Mac. Funniest Shit.
He's one of these guys that like,
he's part of Jamie Foxx is crew and like
always has on like $300 sneakers that
he got at one of these Tete de yeah.
We're celebrities. Go to the tent.
Reagan's Free Shit. This guy tents
are glorious. Yeah, they're great.
Okay.
But Johnny works.
Yeah.
Dues will go and stack up those tents.
Oh yeah.
Sometimes they give away watches and shit.
Oh fuck yeah.
Watches trips there.
Those things are weird.
The representatives are all like
super smiling. [inaudible] super
gray shading if you don't
know what we're talking about.
There's these things they do at like
award show sometimes especially, well,
they'll have like a tent and all
the celebrity before the award show.
Do they do it the day before?
Well, it depends. Some at
the award show itself, they,
I think they give out baskets,
but um,
I know that Nike has a giant tent and
Marina del Rey and it's always the day
before the award show.
You come in and you walk in and you
pick out the base shoe that you want,
we'll call his stripes with color laces.
And he had a whole place that you could
go to. Well, I guess it was like that,
but it was free.
Yeah.
They had a whole place you'd go to that
there would send celebrities there.
This like some talking about, but they
had, that was 24 seven Oh, is that right?
A year round. 24 seven. But
you know, they had hours,
but this lady Tracy's to work there,
she was so nice.
She gave me free sneakers for
like most of my time on TV.
All Nike give you free Nike's just show
up. Yeah, they would send them to you.
They send you like the latest styles,
you know,
they just want you to be
wearing shit like that.
There was this company up in San
Francisco called upper playground.
You ever heard of them?
No. It's real, real cool.
Like I'm Kinda like a Keith Haring,
a graffiti art type of stuff and a little
bit hip hop, but not really, you know,
not oversize and all that.
But they used to outfit a bunch
of the comics and it was great.
I'd go on best week ever with a Fucking,
you pee on my chest and that would just
get boxes of sweatshirts and shirts and
hats. It was crazy. Well,
you remember when like von Dutch became
popular because Ashton Kutcher used to
wear those hats? Yeah.
Yeah. It was ridiculous.
Like the von Dutch thing was
like a collective hypnosis.
Like everybody got hypnotized by like
one of the dumbest looks possible.
A big goofy trucker hat
with the words von Dutch on.
It didn't make any sense. Yeah.
But it became super desirable.
Why do you think it did? Maybe because
Avastin Kosher. Yeah. Beautiful Man.
Perfect bone structure. Yes.
They wanted to be like him.
Maybe it looked cool on him and his
ironic fashion style of, you know,
having this hat on sideways.
Like he doesn't give a fuck.
He's wearing a trucker hat.
He's not even trying,
he's not wearing the perfect fitted
ball cap and a sequence around the,
the ridge of the brand. No, he's
wearing like a goofy little habit.
Shaggy on purpose. Yup. Yup. He
nailed it. Boy Did that guy nail it.
He's good looking enough
that he could look like shit.
Right and still be amazing. Yep. Yep.
Trucker hat was like a way
of showing that, you know,
like he didn't give a fuck.
I'll just put this on.
So how worried I am about my looks right.
And in wearing that trucker hat would
that von dumps logo like you look good.
And so then all of a sudden
these monkeys started buying it.
Monkey see monkey do and everybody's
wearing these God damn shirts.
And it was weird and it
lasted for a wild man last.
It was like a frenzy for like a year
or a year and a half or so. Bless you.
Thank you.
And also credit spun out into a whole
style where guys would wear boots,
like military kind of
are construction boots
that were already,
you'd buy him,
you be up and genes that were beat
up and you know a gas station shirts.
Well that's a big thing with women's
buying pants that are just ripped a shit.
Yeah. Like already. Like
the moment you buy them,
the moment you buy them
at the store or get them,
a lot of people buy things online now.
They don't even go to stores. Yeah,
but they're already torn apart. Like
there's holes all over them. Right.
What is that?
What the fuck is that?
Abraham Lincoln? Well it's like a vintage,
like I like vintage concert tee shirts.
Yes.
Because I like the bands,
but otherwise weathered clothing
that's perf purposefully weathered.
It just feels to me like,
all right, you're spoiled.
You don't work with your hands and you're
trying to make up for it by wearing
some work shit. Yeah.
It's weird that it's site.
Let me feel your hands for a second.
I want to see if you've got any
fucking callouses on your hand. See.
But on the other hand,
like with a girl,
I like it because I like seeing like
the legs poking out all over the,
over the pants, you know, it's this big
gaps in it. You see all the skin. Yeah.
It's exciting. It's like, Ooh,
look at her legs are right there
underneath all this craziness. Yeah.
He'll let you can see your skin at a bunch
of different areas. Like the same way.
I like seeing women in dresses or
skirts, like women in skirts. It's hot.
So basically just the less clothes I just
like, like that's the theme. Jack legs.
Yeah. Girls like reg,
muscular, athletic legs.
I play and then I was telling you
I did this wrong. Right James?
Jamie's getting a hard look at them.
Get the camera and yeah.
Uh,
oh,
I did this. Uh, I told you this charity,
it was a golf tournament yesterday and
I was playing golf with this chick.
Her name was Amy Garcia.
And you, you might know her.
She was in the George Lopez show and
Dexter and now she's the lead in this
Rushmore, uh, show that's coming out.
So she was in my foursome and a man.
She has great legs.
Holy Shit.
All Day long.
She's just like 10 feet in front of me
standing over that ball caught damp.
Hey edition that you have to get into
the pot and over a little bit. Yeah.
You got to pick up that ball and
pick up that ball anyway. Cool.
More God and coolest Shit like one of
those girls that that's like one of the
guys. That was it. And there was a lot
about sports. Yeah. It's always nice.
We could find that. Good luck. Amy, what's
the new shell? I hope Rushmore's ahead.
So we see more solutions on your legs.
Great legs.
Craig Simmons is very happy
with your legs, Puerto Rican.
But a dude wearing pants like that.
You want to smack them right in the mouth.
Pants with holes all over
your fucking pants, right?
Why do you get those crazy holes all
over your pants? What are you doing?
You did it on purpose. You bought those
like all the, what do you, what do you,
Bon Jovi. Yeah. Are you
bunching? Not Bon Jovi. Right.
And why are you wearing this fucker pants.
Okay.
A brown dude.
You went to one of those concerts once.
Oh, I was, I remember you
telling him I was working alone.
I was working at Great Woods
Center for the performing arts,
and I walked into the arena as
I was walking into the arena,
he did that shot through the heart.
That's how they open up the concert.
You never heard anything
like in your life.
The whale of ecstasy at those women
screamed out and a lot of men,
a lot of men will to share. They did.
It was just, no, but I'll tell you what.
I was like, it was a
transformative moment. Yeah,
I remember that because I remember
thinking very clearly like, wow,
what a wild thing these guys have done.
Like they've made a bunch of sounds and
they put it together in a way that like
rhymes and as this rhythm to it and then
they release it and as such an impact
on the people that hear it,
that they just played this in this,
this giant arena, great
woods. I don't know what,
it seemed like more than 10,000 people.
I don't think it's a big fucking place.
And the place erupted.
It was just this raw,
he could hear it out in the parking lot
and I was walking in with these other
security guys and we're like,
Whoa, Holy Shit. Like people went
nuts became a body.
They became beyond themselves.
You become a part of the energy. I mean,
that's a great thing about, first of all,
I fucking love music and I'm
so moved by certain music.
Like if I go to a Bruce Springsteen
concert and he starts singing a song,
it's meaningful to me and I know that
the other 50,000 people are feeling the
same thing. Yeah. That's an incredible
feeling. It's just really transcendent.
It is.
And it's like any other sort of
performing art that you're witnessing.
If you're witnessing someone who's
really nailing it with a bunch of other
people,
it makes it better for some reason.
If you're watching a guy play a guitar
solo and he's just nailing it. Yeah.
And then like you like God damn.
Like if you were there when Hendrix
was at the Roxy and you know,
1960 whatever, yeah. You would, you would,
you would be with a bunch of people
that were watching something special and
it's somehow or another better
than watching it by herself.
Well, it's almost like if it's a band
you really know. It's almost like,
I'm like just now when I sit Bruce
Springsteen, I was like, Huh.
I wonder if Joe Likes Bruce Springs
because some people fucking hate them and
just get that
you can, you can't, you can't deny
that. Some of his fucking album,
some of his songs, younger lands as the
greatest song of all time. It's dude,
he had a bunch of fantastic songs.
Yeah.
Brilliant disguise when he had married
that really hot chick and it didn't work
out. Oh yeah. And he, he put out
that brilliant to sky song. Jesus.
That's a fucking sorrow full
song. I mean, that's a real song,
man. That's that that guy was the,
and still is a bad motherfucker.
But what about after after nine
11 he wrote the rising. Yeah.
And they remember they played it with the,
uh,
they had a choir sing it in front
of the White House on I think was an
inauguration day.
Jesus Christ.
That was powerful.
I might've cried.
Yeah, he's a bad motherfucker. I mean,
he had a bunch of stuff that was just,
you know, like a Anthony Cuneo
would always mock it. You know,
the whole garage.
I'm a blue collar guy down to earth making
ends meet me while he's like a multi
multimillionaire. But that was the
type of shit that he's saying. Right.
But if you get past that,
like some of his stuff,
well Dylan was, you know, he's always sang
for the working man. Yes. He's got money.
I think it's folk music.
Dylan did it in a way that,
you know,
okay.
It was, I don't know, it was a little
flatter or something like that,
but it was more emotion or the
right, I think it was
more of a nod to, um,
felt music like old Hobo
kind of music. Right. And uh,
were as Springsteen I think was
more of like a, um, you know,
arena rock. He was, he was looking for the
big ballot, the big operatic song, like,
like Rosalita thunder road that
you can sing in a fucking wall,
you know, the, in a giant stadium and blow
the place out. Wow. About the river man.
Yeah.
And that came out. I was in high
school when that came out. I was,
it was my first year in high
school in [inaudible] 81.
And I remember that
song came out in there,
but it was like everybody's
jaws dropped. Right? Oh my God.
I got married, pregnant and man,
that was all she wrote. Dude.
It was for my 19th birthday.
I got a union card and a wedding coat.
Yeah,
great line.
Yeah.
Yeah. And this, this is,
there was this message from a lot of
his songs and that message was this
confusion and anx that you're having in
your youth literally might be the freest
you ever are for the rest of your life.
And from here on out,
it's just this horrible struggle to try
to stay sane and try to avoid your vices
and keep your job and keep away
from the heroin and the boots
oohs and all the romance
in your relationship.
And almost no one was doing it in his
songs as long as we're all paying. Yeah.
That is so true. What you just said,
it's about this moment right now. Yeah.
It always is. It's about, um,
you know that tonight, let's
live for tonight. You know,
more than to run live tonight.
I don't, tomorrow's not
going to be good. Yeah. But,
uh, um, what was the line? Uh,
okay.
I can't remember.
Born in the USA is probably the
most ironically misuse song ever,
right? Like how many people have
used that as like a, a pro America,
Paulo tissue, Republican
politicians. Yeah.
I mean, just, just him singing overpowers
the actual content of the song,
which is very anti war,
which he was. Yup. No,
it's about a guy's life falling apart
because of the war and the door was a
mistake. Yeah. There's
so many good songs, man.
Anybody that doesn't think I'm
looking at his shit. Human touch,
tunnel of love streets of
Philadelphia. How, yeah.
God Damn Thunder road. Ooh, fucking song.
Yeah. Jesus. And you go back to
darkness on the edge of town,
which was a really dark oh biblical album.
And you know,
all of Adam raised a cane and
all of this like, you know, um,
just,
just really about
your relationship to your dad.
A lot of it is,
and you know that whether or not you're
going to take over your dad's life,
you're going to lead your own life.
The dancing in the dark held them back.
That's what fucked everybody up.
And he got a little poppy. He got a
little silly. Yup. Got a little silly,
started dancing and shit. And everybody
went, Whoa, Whoa, whoa, Whoa, whoa.
Where's the fucking river, Bro? Where's
the river? We're going down to the river.
He committed suicide.
Are we dancing in the dark?
Right? It's like Billy Joel when he did
uptown girl. Oh, that was the worst.
Same thing though,
right?
Well, I think Billy Joel went through a
real hard period when it started getting
together with Christie Brinkley because
a man like that is not supposed to fuck
a woman like that in nature.
Okay.
And what happens is when you're fucking
a girl who's just an undeniable 10 and
you're this, this very amazingly
talented singer and piano player,
but you know that in the wild,
that woman is not going to take you.
She's going to be with some viking
or something. Doesn't make any sense.
She's this giant supermodel and she's
just stunning and perfect in every way.
And he became a bitch
for a little bit town.
She's been living in town. Well, gotta
give the guy some credit though. I mean,
first of all,
as a musician,
he's amazing that the songs
that people don't talk about,
like the ballot of Billy the kid,
it's a fucking great song.
That's a great song. Scenes from an
Italian restaurant. Yeah. God Damn
Way. You are maybe the most beautiful love
song to sing. It's amazing. Yeah, he was.
He's one of the all time greats.
He just fell apart when he got a 10
he will eat pork a little bit picky.
Got Sober.
I think he was really member.
You got a couple of a couple
of Duis fucking sobriety.
But you know he's selling out Madison
Square Garden once a month every fucking
month. Of course he is. He can do that
anytime he wants for the rest of his life.
He takes his car and from his
house takes them 45 minutes.
Then he goes home that night
after selling out the garden.
He's really fucking Joel. He
deserves it. He earned it.
But is that the way to do it? If you make
it that big and you love what you do,
but you don't want to travel on the road,
just going to go down the street to the
garden once a month. It's amazing. Yeah.
He lives unlike long island on
the, on the, on the ocean. Yeah.
He's in the Hamptons. Yeah. He lives like
right on the ocean. So Desi. Yeah, yeah.
That's his thing, man. Like fixing his
motorcycles, riding motorcycles around.
He apparently broke his arm. Really
bad writing is motorcycles. Oh really?
Fucked up. You still can play piano. Still
plays a shit out of piano. But he like,
he's, you know, he rides
motorcycles. He's taking chances.
He's a risky file.
They say that like the muscles that you
develop when you play piano or guitar,
like your left fingers
when you play guitar,
that you actually build up muscles in
your brain that allow it to be stronger
and a probably recovers
better because of that. Whoa.
I was just reading that because uh,
you know,
you're talking about there was this,
there was this a op Ed piece
in the Times where they were,
this woman was talking about,
she resents Caitlyn Jenner for talking
about how she was always in the wrong
body and that she's really a
woman because at the same time,
so that's acknowledging that the male
brain and the female brain are different.
But the same feminists will tell
you a few try to say that, uh,
that there are different
in the academic world.
You'll get fucking annihilated because
they don't want you to distinguish that
there are any different that they
aren't capable of doing what men can do.
And so they try to say, you can't,
if you're a fucking, uh, you're a,
you're a pig. If you say that women are
different. But then with Katelyn you go,
oh no, she's got the female
brain. Well, which is it?
Well, I don't think there's
saying that they're not different.
I think they're saying that they're,
whatever differences they have are not
intellectual than might be differences of
philosophies or sexuality or,
or,
but not as far as intellectual capacity.
No, that's the issue. That's right.
That's like the big feminist issues
that the treated equal with intellectual
capacity but not necessarily
equal and behavior still,
right? Yeah, the standards. Yeah. I didn't
say better. I said different. Right.
And that's the point of this article is
that you build up muscles as a female
because you're,
you're not picked on the sports team
and then you're not paid as much.
Then you have to give birth.
Then you have to be afraid
of being raped all the time.
Which is something we
don't even think about.
And so you develop muscles in your brain
that make you not really muscles in
your brain.
So I think the neurons just developed
pathways that make it more effective.
And so, um, and so, and men
developed their brains differently.
And so it's so to say that Bruce Jenner
who had the benefit of being a lauded a
athlete and, uh, you know, multimillion
dollar spokesman and whatever else he did,
he got as a man and that to
now say he's a female is like,
no, because you, you don't have all that,
those other pathways that we built up
as a woman. You still have a male brain.
But if a female lived a very male style
of life from the time that she was
really young,
if she grew up in a house with all
brothers in a rural area where she wasn't
really a allowed to express herself in,
you know,
your traditional female way,
and she's living with these, uh,
men essentially, uh, and boys and, uh,
she develops her own pathways in a very
different way. Right. You know, I mean,
she's still a woman and so it's like,
I think like making these
hardcore distinctions.
Like I've heard people say both sides,
I've heard them argue the
Bruce Jenner's a hero.
I've heard them argue that this is a
freak show and then America is in such a
rush to be more and more progressive that
we're ignoring the f like some really
key facts about him and his situation.
First of all,
that he was crazy enough to marry that
woman and and do that reality show and
have that microscope Donna and
slide and it's really disgraceful.
And two that he wasn't paying attention
recently and plowed into a woman's car
with his fucking truck center into
traffic and she died because of it.
She was killed directly because of him
hitting her and pushing her into oncoming
traffic.
A person is not on earth anymore because
of this carelessness and no one is
talking about that at all.
I mean, that's a real issue
with people. I mean, yeah, we,
we, we hope that it's not us
that makes a mistake like that.
It's a horrible mistake to make.
But how is that not as
important or how it is?
Like why is this a big
thing about gender only?
How about about contrition
for this accident?
How about saying like how important it
is to pay attention all the time while
you're driving? I'm so sorry that a
life is not here because of my error.
It is my era and I think it could have
been avoided if I was paying attention
and I didn't plow into this lady.
It could have been avoided.
It is possible to avoid that haunts me.
Not, you know what haunts me. I'm a woman.
Well, the other thing he hopes
holidays for is the fact that he,
he put out this message,
this car Dashi and message to all young
women to be a fucking stupid Horesh
money-driven uh, you know, and
then dating outside the race,
all the things that they're propagating
and those are going to take,
you snuck that in there. Good
is people right now, listen,
I knew Fitzsimmons was one of us.
If you took all my quotes like
that and you stacked them together,
I would be so fucked.
Oh yeah. You know, fortunately we
don't have to worry about that anymore.
No one cares. No one cares
anymore. No one cares anymore.
And you can have a podcast.
You could explain yourself if you,
you've got quoted like that a long time
ago when you didn't have a podcast,
you couldn't explain yourself in
context of what exactly was going on,
how you're fucking around.
Yeah. That's chicken.
Oh yeah. I have guests come out all the
time on my podcast and they're just like,
can you cut out that thing? And I'm
like, man, I usually, I usually will,
but I try to talk them out of it.
But they, especially people
that are straight actors,
they get very concerned because they come
out and then they realize they have a
publicist and that things can be taken
out of context and they all said and get
weird. I had, I had this woman on
from, from transparent, you know,
that show transparent. What does that,
it's the key. It's the transgender shell.
Oh, I think it's on Amazon
prime. Who's The star of it?
Uh,
the guy from Jeffrey Tambor,
who's going to win the Emmy this year
for that incredible. The show is great,
but you think of all people,
we were talking about transgender issues
and she got a little squirmish to any
impropriety and you
don't stick to the line.
Shouldn't even say him and her anymore.
He's supposed to say them and they,
yeah. And you're not
supposed to. Some people,
some people prefer her and Bruce
Jenner up to recently preferred him.
Yeah.
Really supposed to call them Katelyn.
Now I find that a hard transition
calling him Caitlyn Jenner. Fuck it.
I don't find it hard, but I want
to hear it out of his mouth. Okay.
I want you to say,
call me Caitlyn.
Just make a video and I'll
start calling you until then.
I want bus stop signs.
Call me k like it should be on the front
of a magazine. Yeah, call me Caitlyn.
Well,
so I don't the fucking picture he took,
that's another thing people
take issue with is like,
did you have to come out as
a way fee model? He chick.
You couldn't have been just a woman,
like a strong woman.
You had to be this sort of
submissive model type of,
that's his fantasy.
By the way,
if you didn't know that was Bruce Jenner,
you were left alone at home and you were
left alone in a cabin for a weekend and
you just turn to it. Well, unless
I turned to it through Photoshop,
I probably be able to see immediately
what it really looked like.
Do you think that she looks anything
like that fucking photograph?
No. No, no, but I, but I could have beat
off to that photograph and that scares me.
Whatever they did to her face.
That's not healed yet. No,
she's 65 when you're 65 years old.
Takes a long fucking time for
bone shaving to heal. All right.
They did some sort of a 12 hour feminizing
operation on her face, allegedly.
Then I want to hear her say it
until I write. Call me Caitlyn. She,
I'm going by the last interview.
The last interview said that he preferred
the he pronoun and he preferred Bruce
Bruce Jenner. He's a woman as he
talked about genital mutilation,
yet it's not that. It's sexual
reassignment surgery. You
fucking CIS gendered ass.
Fuck. Excuse me, everybody.
We're reassigning you. Shit Lord.
I knew else. They call it, you
don't call it a vagina anymore.
You call it the front hole.
I think you might be making this up.
I swear to Christ the front hole.
Oh fuck me and my front hole.
If a woman who was his fuck him, you,
him, her vagina, he'd biller. But boy,
the Internal Oregon, my internal
organ, that would be really specific.
Maybe if you're like dating the biologist,
but aren't,
isn't every single organ internal? No.
Your skin's an organ. Uh, yeah. Right?
Yeah. Kid went Rogan. Boom. I think,
uh, yeah. Anything other than
postseason acceptable. Eat my pussy.
That's what you want to hear. So
perfect. Perfect. And most women love it.
They love sang pussy. They should.
We love it. They love it. You know,
he says it cray respect. Natasha
Lazaro. She knows how to say pussy.
I bet she does with that little
character that she does that little,
she's just adorable. She's hilarious.
She's so talented. She's very, very smart.
Very smart. Very funny. Very
quick. Yeah. I'm choosing to go.
It's not a huge, how did she not get
here? I mean, not that she won't still,
but she should have been huge already.
You knew it was going to be huge.
Tj Miller. Christina
Palicki. Yes, dude. Yeah.
I saw her fucking destroy the other
night at the comedy store and my jaw was
hanging out with all right.
I said,
I said like you might be one of the
funniest women that's ever walked the face
of the planet.
No Shit for me on Saturday.
The set that I saw her,
I'm like,
I'm trying to figure out who
has more poignant points,
who has more like big laughs, who
has more energy on stage. I'm like,
she's right up there with,
with anybody I've ever seen.
Now she's fucking funny as
Shit, Dude. She's really funny.
I got to watch your whole set again.
Fuck, she's coming down. I'm doing a set.
I'm doing that thing that we did
at the belly room. It's amazing.
The comedy store Saturday
at 10 30 come on down.
I think I asked for her to open for me.
I'm not sure if that's confirmed,
but she may be doing it, but I'll
be doing an hour new material. Uh,
go to my website, click on comedy
store and uh, come fill it up. Yeah.
That is the 11th or the 13th that
is the Saturday night. 13th right?
Yeah. You're going to love it,
dude. We got, we did it together.
I opened for you that. That's
right. Yeah. It's great.
You're going to love doing it on your own.
Reach out and touch everybody.
It's amazing. 90 seats. Can I share
with my other dates? Fuck yeah.
Cleveland. I'm common baby. Jesus.
Hilarity is June 18th through 20 how
great is that club? It's great glove.
Fuck a doctor, grandson,
grand rapids, Michigan.
June 25 through 27 and then I
got dates come up in Houston,
Boston, et cetera. Fits dog.com.
[inaudible] Dot Com was gentlemen also,
I got a TV show. I'm on true TV season
two, how to be a grownup. It's us.
Christina's on it and Tom Thompson,
her and Christina are on it.
And you like giving advice on yeah,
that's a good idea. Yeah, it's just end.
The best thing is is they give,
they'll send you like 20 pages of topics
that they want you to write jokes on
and then comment on.
So it was like the homework that I should
have been doing anyway because it was
all stuff about like how to,
how to deal with babysitters and
shit that you know is my world.
And so I just wrote a hundred pages
of jokes and did them on the show and
then I went through and picked the,
the ones that might be good for stand up
and I swear to God I got 40 minutes in
new material at a two seasons of
the show this year. That's awesome.
Sometimes just forcing yourself in
a position where you have to write,
just forcing, forcing it. We need
to do what we used to do. Me,
you and maybe or somebody else,
sit down at a fucking room
and throw out a topic.
Everybody write on it for 15 minutes.
Talk about,
we wrote whoever has the best shit gets
the other two guys shit that we used to
do that. When did we do that? Did
that with Katar? With Tom Connor.
Oh yeah.
God Damn Dude.
Back in the day we were focused
while we were desperado too.
We're trying to figure out how
to crack the system. Yup. Yeah.
How do you right now, what do you
do? The majority of you were writing?
I throw a lot of notes in my iPhone
and then I'll tweet. I'm not,
I have no issue with tweeting and then
taking the tweet and turning it into a
joke. Did I do on stage? I think it's
almost like a good reminder of premises.
Yeah. I don't have a problem with it
either. People have problem with it.
They're just looking for
something to have a problem.
Yeah. They're like, I don't want my
audience to see the same thing twice.
It's like they're going to see my shit
about five or six times because I'm going
to do on how to be a
grown up after I tweet it.
The worst is when someone
who is a in the audience,
we'll tweet to you like you talked
about that already on Twitter.
It's on and 40 characters.
It was a five minute bid on it.
You fuckhead Jesus Christ. Right? Right.
Yeah. That's where the premise came from.
I thought of it. Then I've
wrote it down. I said,
this would be a funny tweet and I said,
no one. I can get a bit out of that.
People want like it's,
it's really interesting.
Most people appreciate
the creative process,
but there's some people that just want
this constant stream of what they want.
All right,
and then if it's not good, they
shit on you for that. It's like,
what do you want me to do?
Stay of 24 hours a day to come up with
tweets that are different than my stand
up. You know who is
interesting? Woody Allen,
who first it started off as a standup,
amazing albums. Then he started
writing books like without feathers.
Remember those? They were
like funny short stories. No,
I wasn't aware of this great book called
without feathers. It's re you will,
it's one of the few books
you will laugh out loud,
like confederacy of dunces kind of funny.
And then he starts making movies.
But if you go back and you look
at the stories in his standup,
he also wrote about them and his books
and then they became plot lines in his
movies. That's kind of fascinating
to me to watch that progression.
It is, it's, I, I love
watching the progression of
bits. When I see a guy like,
you know,
like you come down to the store and you
have some new piece on something you're
doing and then I'll see it two weeks
later and it's got all this new shit on it
and I'd love that. Yeah,
I'll see it a month later.
And it's got this rhythm to it now it's
from Japan and that's still the weird
thing about these bits that
when a person finally sees it,
like if you do a Netflix
special and they see this
chunk that you've been working on
for the past six, seven months,
that thing sometimes is even remotely
similar to what it started out as.
The more fun.
They move and they shift and you push
them together and it's w I love watching
that process. Some people don't
want to see it. Some people,
they just want a constant
stream of absolutely new stuff.
The problem with that is I
agree that the more new stuff,
the better. I try to write as
much new stuff as possible,
but bits only get better if you keep
doing them right and to get them to that
Samurai sword, razor sharpness,
hammering that steel,
they have to be done a bunch of times. You
have to, you can't just write them out.
You have to perform them
in front of the crowd.
You have to figure out what's wrong
with your performance, what's right.
I the sat and he got to listen to
your tape sats. I, and I'm, I'm,
I've been fanatical about
that for 25 years. I does.
I think I've listened to probably 20% of
every, of all the sets I've ever done.
That's very good.
I'm not that high,
but I have all of them.
Every set that I do,
I tape and I make notes afterwards.
One of the things I started doing
is right after I get off stage,
I sit down with a pad and important things
that I remember about that set. Like,
oh, there was a hiccup in the transition
from this to that. There was a,
there's a better way to do this.
I gotta figure out how to
tie these together and all,
there's a crazy tagline after that
that I came up with on the fly
or like this bit there's more,
there's more like you feel like you can
stretch it out more and you got it and
you don't always remember to keep writing
on it and that it's like you say if
you don't, part of it for me is like I
got to go on stage in the right head.
I have to like fucking take a shower,
I'm going to work, like show up.
Having looked at my notes and you know,
not get too fucking caught up and
talking to people before I go on,
I want to go on and really like be there
and then I could fuck around after the
show.
Yeah.
You want to be in the zone that each one
of those bits requires and they're all
different.
And that's one of the things about like
knowing where to put a bid in your act.
You go to like,
I have like these areas in my act when
I think of is like hills and valleys
where this is like,
this is like slow contemplation,
thinking about how weird something is.
And then there's the big hills,
like we're going to go on sprint and a
sprint and then we're gonna come back
after this. And you've got to figure
out where to put these things,
where they all belong and you've
got to move them around. So fun man.
And that's where it's really like a
jigsaw puzzle is because you're trying to
take the bit,
you're trying to create those hills and
valleys and then you're trying to take
the material that's related and
keep it all in the same area.
And then you're also taking, you want to
mix new stuff with old stuff and then,
and then it's like,
you know,
at a certain point you go to do a
special and you're like, all right, I,
I got a lock down on this shit.
I can't keep moving it around because
then you got to nail down the transitions.
Yeah. Yeah. Everybody seems to uh,
agree that there's somewhere
between a year and two years. It's,
that's the,
the far ranging guys say two years.
The guys who really like to turn things
over on a regular basis, say a year,
but after a year or after two
years, it's done. It's done.
You can never do it again. You got to
throw it onto a DVD and get it out.
So round somewhere around a year is when
you have to start thinking about it.
You start saying, you know what,
it's September. Come January,
I want to record my special.
So then you have to set up the deal
and then you have to set up the venue.
And a lot of times things are books seven,
eight months in advance
anyway when it comes,
especially if it comes to a theater.
If you wanted to do it at a theater,
you have to do it.
Wayne advanced a lot of times and then
you start prepping for it and start
building toward and then it's less a
matter of writing new shit than it is a
matter of like sharpening man.
That stuff as much as possible.
That gets weird for me because
then once I get rid of the special,
like I get rid of all that material,
then I start fresh.
Then sometimes it becomes harder because
I haven't been writing as much as I've
been sharpening.
You know,
I've just been going over the
same material over and over again,
so I got to Kinda like, I may
might have to revamp that. I might,
I might just start just film a
bunch of sets. Like you know,
I was at the Irvine
Improv this past weekend.
They have a camera that they have set
up in the back of the room and when they
filmed the thing, it's in the,
on the screen in the green room.
So you're watching it in the green
room and it's like, this is perfect.
Just one camera. Just one camera
like this. This is the actual show.
This is what you'd see if you
were in the audience. Right.
Like you don't have to do this any
other way. As a matter of fact,
this is the least distracting way.
Like literally put out chunks of you
just on one camera. No crowd shots.
Yes.
One Cameron my other option
a the of two extremes.
The other option is to buy
a fuck load of Gopros. Yeah.
And strapped into people's
heads. Yeah. And uh,
what did you ever see a hand
them out to people and they,
it's like you don't want you to go to
Disneyland and you get on the star wars
ride. They give those goggles.
Everybody will get a Gopro. They'll,
they'll press record on it.
And then at the end of the night,
you throw your Gopro in the bucket. Yeah.
And we'll have somebody edit that shit.
But did you ever see David Tell,
did that show the comedy
underground and he would give out?
I think one it was one go
pro he put into the crowd.
Oh see that mix it together on original
will now because yours is like I want to
do, I want to do like 200
Gopros and uh, give people,
cause I figure it's a bunch of people
are not going to turn them on or if they
fuck it up or someone's going to
get drunk and spill booze on it,
you're not going to
get every single GoPro.
You could also tell people don't
forget to pan around and show,
show the people at your table
laughing. Yeah. And that's,
that would be bad ass gay cause it would
be three d you'd have to have a lot of
security. You have to make sure
that nobody leaves the Gopro to,
somebody would try to steal your GoPro.
Beastie boys filmed
a movie like this meant two thousands
they gave 50 fans in the crowd.
Digital Cameras and oh did together from
all their views from different angles.
And the top of the area was it called?
It's called a awesome,
I shot that or something
very close to that. Awesome.
I fucking shot that fucking shot.
That, oh, what a great idea.
Dammit. I'm like seven years
later. I thought it was just
a couple of years later.
But what if he streamed it every night?
What if you had like five cameras
and somebody just did the,
did the cutting and it was a stream of
every set that you do from five point
goes down.
Yeah. Then what's the point in releasing
it as a professional? You don't,
you don't,
it's an ongoing thing. If you want
to see Joe Rogan almost like a,
well I guess with that um, periscope
basically periscope your shows, you
know it seems like a bad idea right now,
but ultimately it's probably going to
seem like a good idea like that maybe as
well how people are going to release
their specials. Just stream them. Yeah.
When you really stop and think about
it like Kinda everything streaming now,
you know as long as
it's on demand as well,
you know like some sort of like a Netflix
type deal where it's a live stream and
then it's available for download
anytime you want afterwards.
Can I periscope a little
bit of this if you must,
if you must.
Well this is my thing about those things
are fun every now and again but they
really do distract,
right?
They distract the like when when a bunch
of people around you and everyone's
periscoping,
it's hilarious.
Like it happens at the comedy store
all the time with periscope each other,
but at the end of the day it
kind of does distract, you know?
It's like how many like actual
conversations you're having, how many,
how many sit down,
let's talk about some shit.
Let's fit once you start periscoping
and instagramming and selfieing and
tweeting this, tweeting that.
There's a balance in that.
In the last side of that balance,
he comes a very non intimate
interaction between everyone involved.
I've been around like a bunch of like
really techie people and watch them barely
communicate with words other than talking
about the things they just tweeted,
talking about the things that somebody
else tweeted. We should tweet this.
I should get a picture of that. I want
to Instagram this snap chat is going on.
What exactly. Exactly. They're
talking about new filters we need,
I got this new APP. It's way better
filters and look what it does look good.
It does and it's like the,
the,
the tech conversation and the tech
related as far like sending and receiving
shit overwhelms the,
the,
the human interaction overwhelms
it to medium is the message. Yeah,
and there's a lot of that going on.
There's a lot of that.
You don't think of it as tech related
because you're talking about some real
life shit that's happening. Not near you,
but it's going through the phone. Right.
That's the whole deal. It's
like you're it, there's not much
people to people. Communication. Yeah.
Was like this weird
interface that we're sharing.
Whether we do it solo or we look at
each other's stuff that we do it on or,
well, when you think about language
and the fact that it is, um,
you know, it's a dumbed down
version of our thoughts.
If you have to put your
thoughts into words,
you're obviously compromising the scope
of your idea and the fullness of your
idea because it's got to
fit into these words. Right.
Then you go to this second level of
digital communication where now you're
seeing a dumbing down of the words because
you have to limit what you're doing,
where you're looking, you're your
presence with the other person.
Everything is then taken to an even
simpler place than it was before,
so it's completely flat.
Hmm.
Human interaction is very bizarre,
but just thinking about what you
do for a living, you're your job.
Yeah.
Is to elicit a very specific
response out of people.
Right. One of all the
range of emotions. We're,
we're like doctors that are specialists
in this one emotion. One area.
Yeah.
And then creating it as
well as delivering it.
So creepy with a live.
Yeah.
Sick of it. Sometimes the whole idea
of comedy, I just can like, Ugh,
I don't want to be funny. I don't want
to see anything funny for like six hours.
Definitely going to take time off. Yeah,
but that's a, that's the balance issue.
That's like as a,
as a comedian,
I think it's one of the most important
things is to have some sort of a balance
in your life. Yeah. You're,
you're into other things as well.
Things that are not even remotely funny.
Right.
That those things are the things that
you eventually get humor from. You know,
like for me,
I've always had this lifelong fascination
with wild animals and the wildlife and
I've gotten a lot of material from the,
the natural world,
but a lot of that stuff,
like when I'm washing those things,
I'm not even thinking for a second
then I'm getting material out of it.
I'm watching some documentary on
water buffaloes and lions. Yeah.
Engaged in this Ian's long
conflict for survival and all.
I'm thinking it was just like, what
a crazy, what a crazy thing this is.
You can capture on film.
Yeah.
That we're so insulated and isolated in
these cities that we can't even imagine
what the fuck is going on on this guy
had this guy on the other day there was
telling me about the charter
to channel islands. Yeah.
You're the channel islands is just
that water is overflowing sharks.
No Shit. Yeah. That's the sign off Santa
Barbara. Yeah, it's right out there.
Right out there. Those, those waters
are apparently just filled with sharp.
Wow. They catch them. They
caught the world record.
Maaco shark around this area.
Um, I think somewhere around, uh, I
want to say like Huntington Beach,
somewhere around that area.
She isn't going to become a close
at our sure that the global warming,
are they those out works
they see there seems
be more science seemed
to be the ocean is going to get closer
and closer. It's going to rise. Right.
And here's my theory,
right around the time the ocean starts
rising as when we figure out how to take
salt out of the ocean and we just
start socking that bitch dry.
Well, like what are you going to rise
up on us as fast as we can use you. Oh,
good luck with that. Have you ever
seen an almond field, sir? Yeah.
And then we'll just start sucking water
out of the ocean and the ocean will dry
up and then people in Malibu will get
really pissed because their beach front,
they'll be like looking at this like
100 yards of sand till they get to the
water. Yeah. There's that. There's that
giant river up in northern California.
They just got dried out.
Completely call like the salt
ocean salt sea or something.
What you're talking about the salt
and sea salt and sea, right? Yeah.
That's not try it out completely.
It's just still exist. Pretty.
It's pretty far gone on the ocean front.
All his ocean front houses there,
they're looking at nothing.
Well the salt and season inland sea
that was created by the Colorado River.
The Salton Sea was an accident, right?
It was a, they had opened up the, uh,
there's amazing, I think John Waters
did a documentary on, it was at waters.
I think it was him,
but this is an incredible documentary
on how this all happened and it at one
point in time that was like
where these really rich people,
Hollywood celebrities.
Sonny Bono was a big fan of the place
when Sonny Bono was a congressman.
Is that what it was? Yes, the
center, no. Congress congress,
when he was a congressman before
he died and that skiing accident,
he was working to desalinate that that
whole ocean area and try to revive the
salt and sea because when he was
younger that place was hopping.
It was hot and it was like giant
resorts and golf courses and mansions.
And I think a lot of the water
though was runoff from from crops.
Agricultural runoff was what poisoned did.
That's what fucked it up.
Plagues and pleasures on the salt
and Sea John Waters. Yeah, that's it.
That's the one. It's amazing. And you
have to watch cause I had no idea.
I had heard about it from people
like something about salt and sea.
And I was like,
I thought it was just like an area that
they called the salt and sea, you know,
like the inland empire, right. Some
of the empire, you know what I mean?
But they call it the inland empire.
The empire, the inland empire.
They called the inland empire,
the same dragons there.
Where's the drawbridge is not an
empire. Like this is just a town. Yeah,
we don't have a mayor. We did. So I
thought the salt and sea was like that.
I thought it was like
this area that was just,
they just named it that there's
no c in the middle of it.
And then I've heard the story and then
I watched this documentary and it's
insane. So it was a
regionally, just it amazing.
Verdad water from the Colorado
River. Yes. And then they got,
they got fish in there, like a lot
of ocean fish, Tilapia. And um,
people would catch him and
they would fish for him.
And now it's so bad that there are shores
of the beach that is completely filled
with dead.
Look at those dead fish completely
filled with dead fish bones.
They have millions. That's
bones. Yeah, they have sand,
but it's not sand.
It's just dead fish bones.
Right. There's also bird habitats
there that are getting fucked.
And it is nowhere for the birds to go.
Well we don't, we didn't realize until
recently a lot of folks didn't. Elise,
how much agriculture was
going on in California.
I mean California is all the way up to
San Francisco. If you take the five,
you just run into farms.
It's everywhere.
There's a lot of agriculture
and apparently a lot of
like tomatoes and most of
the almonds and all this different shit
gets grown in California and California
is using a lot of fucking water.
Oh yeah. Rice patties up north.
Do we really? Yeah. Whoa. That's a lot
of water. That's a lot of water. Yeah.
Everywhere is a lot of water elements
we're exporting Ahmed's. Yeah, sure.
Alfalfa to they export a fuck
load of Alfalfa apparently.
And it's using a Chihuahua beef.
Right. I Dunno who use it, but um,
you know, it's a big business.
The agricultural business
in California is giant.
And it's just now because of this
now going on four year drought,
they get to see like what,
how much water they really require.
Cause before it was just sort of, they had
enough water, they used a lot of water,
but they had enough water and now that
they don't use any less and there's none
coming in,
it's getting weirder.
Well it's all about the Colorado River
and who gets dibs on it first then it's
all about who had it first.
So you've got,
you've got farms way up north that are
at the mouth of it and they grab all the
water they want and you can't
tell them how much they can take.
And so as it gets further down and more
and more people are taking more and more
of the water and also that the,
what do you call the water underground?
The table? Yeah, the table there.
They're pulling from that. Yeah.
They're making more wells, right? The
Poland from the in in ground water.
And they say that the earth crust is
going to start collapsing because of it.
Isn't that fucking crazy that we didn't
know that there was water under us all
the time. Like I remember the first
time I, uh, went to a place that had a,
well I went wait a minute,
hold on. How does this work?
And the guy was like, well,
everywhere under us,
our rivers and rivers of water and
some of them stronger than other ones.
And which you got to do is you got to
find the right river and do you find the
right river? You dig down to get to it
and then just pull water from it? I go,
it's just constantly has water in it.
Yeah. So there's like, this is not solid.
We're on this thing that looks
like it's ground and it's solid,
but there's rivers under there. Yeah.
Like how far down is this fucking river?
You know, it varies few hundred feet,
a thousand feet, couple thousand feet.
But if you get down long
enough and the right area,
you're going to run
into rivers. Yeah. But,
and they never pop up on their own. And
that's the weird thing. You never see
groundwater very rarely, right?
I mean, when you see a spring,
it's usually coming down from the top of
the mountains from the glacier run off
or the snow melting. Yeah. But there's,
there's some underground water and
that's what's really become an issue with
farmers that they're suck
in that stuff dry. Right. It's
all becoming an issue and they,
and the equipment's getting better
and better to suck it out. And uh,
like you said, the need is just
getting greater and greater.
I think all I need to do,
figuring out how to get the fucking salt
out of the ocean water and bon voyage,
that's it.
You're going to have,
you're going to see that shore is
just gonna grow and grow every year.
We're going to literally suck the ocean
that like a giant Straw able to start
from one continent to
the next human robot,
Munster Straw sucking machine
that takes the ocean now,
which is huge tubes that are
as big as the Holland tunnel.
Just vole we,
everybody would be pissed cause
that's all you would hear all day.
You'd try to go to sleep each to have a
nice place to Santa Monica for they set
up the straw. Yeah. Right. Two o'clock
in the morning is when they turn it on.
It's fucking giant machine,
but we need water everywhere.
It just piles of fucking salt.
They pulled out and they say the other
thing would happen is once we start doing
that is because they feed the salt
back in is that the oceans we become so
salinated who would kill all the fish?
Well,
they wouldn't be able to feed it back
in and the more that has to take it to
Utah, dump it in the mountains,
giving them Mormons. No, De Vida,
they take it and they pour it over the
nuclear waste that they left. Right.
Like you're pouring salt and just stay,
I mean this isn't that where they
buried the nuclear waste. Right.
Open up those tubes and pour it in there.
Fuck it.
You could have a mountain of salt out
there and then people would take your
mountain assault. You know there's
a mountain of salt in, where was it?
Germany that they've been chipping away
at for years and it's flat at the top
now because they've literally removed
all the songs. It was assault mountain.
Yeah.
Pull that picture up because it's the
most bizarre thing because it really does
look like a giant white mountain.
Apparently it's all salt and they
just been eaten away at it. Wow.
He'll get that thing. No
Shit. Not incredible weight.
That's naturally form. Yeah.
It's a natural salt mountain.
What in the actual fucking shit is that?
Look at that thing.
That's crazy. It's a salt
mountain. Cool. Go to the top. Ooh.
Pulled out one. Everything is lush. No,
no, no. The one looked at. Sorry though.
They'll look down one on the
upper left hand corner. Yeah.
See if you could spread it
out. Whoa dude. What is Damn,
how did that salt pile just pop
up under the ground like that?
It's funny that they're taking it
from the top. They must've, you know,
the Germans,
they even take it from the top first.
We can be here mining salt for
a long time or a short time.
We can make a lot of money
or we can buy up to you.
You must learn from the lessons of the
Futura do not to take on a salt the
mountain on two fronts. If you'll take
on this salt mountain from the bottom,
you will cut out its legs. It
will fall on you. You will. When
did the chairman's turn?
Raj? Is that Russian?
I'm just trying to be a Nazi will
fall on you trying to be evil.
Yeah, they get to the top chip away at
it. How long have you been doing that?
No fucking size of it. It's so weird.
Oh, it's this weird aberration.
Just popping up out of the ground
just doesn't seem to make sense.
Did Hitler turned around the
economy of Germany? It's crazy.
1976 had been doing it.
Oh my God. Look at this.
As of January,
2014 had covered 230 acres and contained
approximately 188 million tons of salt
with another 90 tons being added every
hour around 6.5 million tons a year.
How's it being added? I don't know. Oh,
so it's a heap, is that what it's saying?
Okay, so it's on a mountain. Oh,
so it's not naturally occurring.
Yeah.
I mean number of sites where KNS
chemical company dumps sodium chloride,
common table salt,
a biproduct of Topo Tash mining and
processing a major industry in the area.
Oh, we're totally wrong. Yeah. Okay,
so that's a pile. So they're taking it
from the mines and they're just like,
that's why it's like a pyramid.
So then they take it off the top of the
pile and then they're processing it.
Beautiful. Wow. The amount of
salt that goes into the region,
soil and rivers is enormous
due to the high salt levels,
the surrounding soils become
virtually baron and only hallow file.
Hello file.
I will fight halophyte
halophyte plants can grow there.
The Wira,
w e r r a river has become so
salty that up to 2.5 gallons,
g, l, whatever that means, chloride ions,
which is salted and
parts of the Baltic Sea,
that few freshwater organisms
can survive in it. Whoa.
Fucking hey man,
that's salty.
And they lose their license to keep
dumping salt the facility until 2030 and
they just toxic. The whole
place is just salt toxic. Wow.
That's nuts. So I thought, wow,
that makes more sense though that it's
a pile than a weird white mountain that
just didn't make any sense.
Like why is that there? Yeah,
I guess salt comes from
the sea and as a byproduct,
no where else salt comes from
it. I don't know. Salt mines.
So there definitely are salt mines,
but like why does it exist
some places and not others?
Like that's the most bizarre thing is
like there are certain plants that grow
over areas that are likely to hold
diamonds. Is that right? Yeah. Like what?
Yeah. Yeah. How the fuck did they figure
that out? How the fuck do you find?
Forget about finding water.
How about finding diamonds?
Some weird byproduct of pressure and Cole.
Yeah.
What the fuck.
And once you find them,
it's a fortune.
A fortune.
Just it's dirt or it's a fortune
and there are a girl's best friend.
She doesn't even know these fucking rocks.
They live in Africa.
Can you really talk to
her when you're down?
They've been under the ground
forever and ever and ever.
That's such a hoary statement about women,
isn't it?
Diamonds are a girl's
diamonds or your best friend,
like you care about more than any human.
You care about this
fucking expensive rock.
Well that's like the biggest affront to
something like the feminist movement is
the women that are just total sellouts
diamonds.
They're my best friend. Yeah. But if
you want, you want to marry me? Yeah.
I want you to buy a house.
Oh,
I met this girl the other night and she's,
we're shooting this pilot up in Hollywood
hills and we're at this house and it's
huge and it's got like five units.
That house has been split up into five
units and you can see the Hollywood on
one side. You can see all of
La. On the other beautiful.
The house is worth about $4 million.
And the woman that is a, that owns it,
we're talking to her and I
said, oh, how long have you
had this house? She goes, oh,
I got it about nine months ago.
And she's got this accent I can't place.
It's maybe Israeli,
it's maybe Argentinian or something.
And she says that she's been
dating this guy for three years.
And he started this company with his
wife and the company was worth $200
million.
So then he was divorcing his wife.
So during the divorce the
wife dies and she goes,
so he was only getting out of 100 million.
She goes, but then, uh, the wife died,
so now he gets a hold $200 million. So
I said to him, I want to get married.
And he said, he's not ready. And I
said, well, I'm ready. You need to,
you need something to let
me know that you're serious.
So he bought her a $4 million
house, the car, the whole deal,
and then she turns around
and rents out all that.
She split it up into five units and rents
them all out and she's hustling good
for her. Yeah. She used a pussy properly.
That's right. She got herself a victim.
You know, there's a lot of mercy. I
mean, she was, she was attractive,
but she was not worthy of $1 million.
He was supposed to come by,
but he didn't come by. I would imagine
he was older. Probably were work. Yeah.
It's probably wreck.
Just want someone to touch him.
He's worth a fuck load of money. It just
gives her what she needs. It's like that.
The guy that owned the clippers,
sterling,
my girlfriend bought her a bunch of shit.
Yeah. It, everybody was like, you know,
look how much money spent on alert. He got
off cheap. All right. You know, I mean,
the whole thing, the whole thing was
ridiculous. Yeah. Like what was he doing?
He's paying for her to be around him.
He's paying,
he's paying her her mortgage
or got her a place to cars,
Bentley's Ferrari's and shit.
That's what happens.
Like why is that so shocking to people?
It's like when it actually gets exposed
like that, people had no clue. Of course,
it's a cliche. What do you
spend on a girlfriend? You know,
you got to ask the average person
that proportional to his income.
That's fucking nothing.
It's a cheeseburger.
Proportionally you spend more money to
take your girl to dinner and a movie and
he's a billionaire. A billionaire
is a thousand million dollars.
Yeah, so he probably spent
less than a million on her.
It probably spent a couple million, I
think all told the wife is suing her know.
Oh that. Yeah. It is more cause
he would, there was jewelry.
There was a bunch of shit. Yeah. Did
you are a lot townhouse, a lot of shit.
There's a lot of shit I'd imagine some
cash changed hands to do. You know what?
I heard this one woman say, she goes,
I bet it wasn't even the wife's idea.
I bet it was his idea.
Use the wife to sue her to get the money
back and it makes sense. I was like,
God damn. It does make sense. Yeah.
Follow the paper trail on that.
Then I got nervous talking
to her. I was like, oh,
I didn't even think
that what Jesus Christ,
can you delete that photo,
that Selfie you took with me?
I think we're playing tic TAC toe in.
This bitch is playing chess play planning.
Many moves ahead like, Whoa, I
guess you could do it that way.
Because the idea was like the CIC
set him up and he was like, Oh,
do you think you're going to profit from
this? Get us again, right guys again.
All right. Cause if he sues her, it
looks bad and it looks vindictive.
Looks like he's trying to sue
her for what she did to him,
which I think he has every right to
quite honestly. I mean what he said,
first of all,
he didn't use a single racial slur or
if people jumped all over that guy for
that.
But the actual words that he said where,
I don't want you taking pictures
with these guys. That's it.
He didn't say the n word. He literally
even said, I don't mind if you fucked up.
And that was a part of that conversation.
I don't care if you fucked him,
like he didn't have any exclusive deal
with her and this was a totally private
conversation.
And so somehow or another she releases
it and of course he should sue her.
Like, like what? Like what kind of,
what kind of you think that was giving
you cars for it was giving you a car is
to shut the fuck up. Well
not only that, like it,
it winds up costing him
literally costing him the team.
Like he had to sell the team.
Yeah.
Like it became such a scandal
and such a PR disaster.
Such a cluster fuck.
The way the media reported,
the way they didn't talk about the fact
that they obviously had some weird open
relationship where he was saying,
hey, I don't care if you fucked them.
Like everybody concentrated on, don't
take pictures, don't take pictures,
don't take pictures. Yeah. He's an old
dude with a hot young girlfriend charity.
I don't like the idea that him saying
that he didn't want her to take pictures,
that this should be enough, that you
could take his team. That's insane.
But you know,
it goes back to what we were talking
about earlier with like what we can get
away with on a podcast versus what
somebody else can get away with.
And you think about what he said
versus what we just sent my joke.
My joke is more harsh than what he
said and I'm not gonna lose anything.
And I think the argument against him
was that he was a dick. He was a Dick,
he was a dick all the time.
And that people didn't like him.
And so that wasn't a loved guy.
It wasn't like this.
Like when the Joe Paterno thing happened
and found out that he knew about San
Dusky and the trauma station,
like people were devastated
because Joe Paterno was like this,
like really loved guy. But
you know, he was the coach,
obviously 10 you got Kramer.
I mean,
here's the guy that had a fucking 10 year
run on the biggest sitcoms in history,
most lovable guy on the show and one
buck and three minute interaction.
And that dude is a ghost. He's a
ghost. Have you seen him lately?
No, I haven't seen him.
No, he doesn't do anything.
He's probably just eating
through that Seinfeld money.
He doesn't do stand up anymore. Does
he? Doesn't come to the La call.
I haven't seen him at any of the clubs.
I haven't seen him on TV.
I haven't read about him.
That was a really tricky situation for
him to try to get into standup because he
had gone from Seinfeld too.
He had at least one other show
that didn't work. At least one.
I want to see that too.
Um,
and then he just started
coming to the clubs and,
but he had done standup before
Seinfeld a long time, right? Yeah,
but he took a long time off,
especially took a long time off the La
clubs and then he would come out there
and really probably should
have done something where
it was more like an evening
with, what was his name again? He's
not Kramer. What the fuck's his name?
Michael Richard and evening with my
colonized in a lot of ways.
If he just did a laugh factory Gig,
like an evening with Michael Richards,
this had Michael Richards fans show up
and he tried to work out material until
he developed a set, then they'd be
in on the context of who he is. Yes.
It wouldn't be offended by that.
Something like that. Not only that,
he would get his audience wipe end.
He W that too.
And you also wouldn't have him competing
with actual real standup. Yeah,
because when you're doing the
laugh factory on a Friday night,
you're doing it with five other people
on the show who might have sitcoms.
They might be out there doing the road
on a regular basis hustling and they're
throwing heat and they have real jokes
and you go up there and you want to do a
bunch of pratfalls and you, you, you know,
you don't really have anything to say.
He tried to be silly and he would like
to ad Lib and it would fail miserably.
Yeah, he'd do concepts and it, the
thing is like that and that wasn't new.
I went to,
I was at the Improv and Louis C k one
night and Louis' father who he pretty
estranged from his whole life and he was
kind of like reconnecting with and his
father's from Mexico Jewish guy.
And so Louie invites him to the Improv
to see Louie do stand up for the first
time.
And so Louise,
like I've never seen Louie nervous to
go on before and before he goes on,
Michael Richards goes up and there's a
couple in the front row that's Jewish and
they haven't done anything wrong,
but he starts,
he's doing that character and he
goes, so it's gone. Oh you kikes,
he leaves you big news, big nose. Jube
asked is like saying all this stuff.
But in the same way that he said
the black stuff, he didn't mean it,
but he had no control of what
he was doing as a performer.
And he thought that it
was all like a calculated
risk and that we'd all get that this
was a character bit. And Louie was so,
his father was clearly like, he's
fucking Jewish. What? And He's thinking,
this is what my son does. This is
like the environment my son works in.
Wow. Did it fuck with it when you went
into this set now. So that was great.
The problem with the guy was
he, he wasn't skillful. Right.
And he was in the major leagues. Yeah.
And he was really insecure about it.
And that was why had that reaction
to those people that heckled them.
The reason why he called those guys
the n bomb was because those guys were
yelling out the, it wasn't
funny. It wasn't like that.
He just picked on them for no reason.
They started giving him a hard time
about not being funny about bombing,
but they were right. They
were right. You know,
and he didn't like it and he didn't,
he was uncomfortable and
didn't know how to handle it.
And he might've been on the,
yeah, y'all, Sean. He might've,
he might've been on Dat Sun. Yeah.
I hear for things from people mine.
I hear things.
I ain't might've been on that shit.
He would get confident as a motherfucker,
say hello to my little friend,
the n word
that was, that was the first
of those videos. First of
those really viral videos.
This was what I was going to point
this out earlier and I didn't,
but I forgot when those moments
when you're trying to be funny.
Not that moment, obviously.
Cause I was just,
there was such a poorly thought out
idea. It didn't make any sense. What?
So you can't just yell at somebody.
You can't just do that. You just can't.
You just can't do that.
You can't expect that people are gonna
think that's really funny and just so out
to left field. So
nonsensical. So retarded.
But there's these moments where people
take chances and they'll try to be funny
and there's a split second between
that idea enters your head and you say,
run with it. Yeah. And you run with it
and it's sucks. And you're like, Shit.
Especially if you're young or you're
nervous or you're not very good at telling
jokes.
Like how many people have said something
they wish they could go back in time.
And I hold back. Right. Just
cause they're just not skillful.
Well,
and there's only one way to deal with it,
which is to address what just happened.
Yeah. In an honest way. It's hard to do.
It is for a young comic,
forget it.
You just want to get away from that as
quick as possible and you don't realize,
no, you got to double
back and go into it again
or you're just alienate them.
They know what just happened.
Everybody knows what just happened.
Yeah.
Everybody can feel it and it's not going
to go away unless you go back and let
the air out of it.
For a guy like him to go from Seinfeld
to essentially be in an open miker who's
super famous is one of the
most bizarre journeys ever.
Yeah.
I mean that guy was essentially,
he had the skill of someone who is
just beginning in standup comedy,
but yet he's going on at the laugh
factory after dom Irrera. Yeah.
I mean don,
my rare raw and Dane Cook and all these
guys are killing and and killing and he
goes up. Yeah. Jesus. It's
a terrible place to be.
The only way to really
do that I think is to to,
if he had a smart age in a smart manager,
they would cultivate like an act for him.
Like have someone work with them,
get a guy like you or a guy like,
um,
you know,
like Tony Hinchcliffe is great at writing
bits for people and you have a guy
like come with some premises for you
and send me work like second
tier cities and do, um,
you know, just to sets where
you're not going to be. Absolutely.
And let people in on what
the fuck you're doing.
Don't just show up and pretend
you're a real stand up, you know,
let people in on the fact that you're,
you're working on some new
bits you're working on,
it's together. You guys are
helping me do this. Well, you know,
who started from scratch from a
pretty high place is um, chill. Uh,
what's his name from talk soup.
Oh, Joel Mchale, Joel Mchale.
And they'd never done standup.
And it was like, you know,
had gotten huge from that Shell. And then
he just decided to start doing standup,
but he'd go to a theater and he play a
lot of clips from the shell and he kinda
did a, like you said, a one man show
kind of a thing that had stand up in it.
And then I think over time he transitioned
into it just being full because that
dude,
he could sell 2000 seats out of the gate,
but he didn't really know what to do,
but
it was,
he would do a monologue on a show.
So in a sense it was kind of doing
standard. I like the way Craig, uh,
killed Kilborne does. Right. That was the
other guy though. Irish dude. So yeah.
Anymore. Ferguson, Craig Ferguson,
that guy. The way that guy does it,
like he does stand up. I mean, I don't
know if he did stand up before, but did,
he did,
but it seemed like it because he does
stand up when he does his own thing.
He did Improv. Oh, did
it? Yeah, he was like, uh,
I think he might've been part
of whose line is it anyway,
at some point we're just making shit up,
look it up.
Um, but either either or. He was, uh,
doing essentially stand up in his
monologues as, as Joel Mchale.
So even though maybe he hadn't done a lot
of standup, like out in the clubs. Yeah.
He was still kind of doing it
on TV all the time. Yup. Yeah.
He doesn't do it anymore.
Right. Let me stop.
Did he stop? I think he did. I guess he,
he's doing movies. Yeah, he's got that.
Is that sitcoms still on community?
I think it is. Right? It's on Netflix now,
right? It's done. He's a really nice guy,
man. He's a great dude. I did a
episode of a show. Yeah. Shit. Yeah.
Really, really nice guy. Super easy
to get along with love standups. Yeah.
There's a lot of respect for Stan. He's
just like very normal, you know, like,
hey man, what's up? Hey, what's going
on? Thanks for doing this. Like,
there's no weirdness.
You know the weirdness that
you get sometimes when you
do somebody who's gay or
something and hanging out
with someone like yeah. Like,
yeah. So he was a genuinely funny
guy. So for a guy like that,
it's like you're so many headstarts.
They're like,
I don't think Richards is a genuinely
funny guy. I think he's just a
really good comedic like committer.
He commits to call son of a guy.
Yeah.
I mean like when you would
slide into every episode,
apparently Larry David did not like
that. Yeah, I could see that. Yeah.
Cause it was like so sticky.
Right?
It was so obvious that it was going to
happen in every episode. He would come in,
it was like, it was too big. It comes
that Linnaean squigy moment. Hello? Yeah.
Always walk in. I'm like,
yeah, but who would be dumb
enough? She's a hell. Exactly.
But I think this, I liked when
he would do that. It's just,
it didn't make the show less awesome.
I mean it was definitely
a more slap sticky.
Yeah. Some rains. That's the
best way of putting it. Yeah.
Comedy Range is important.
I like really stupid jokes too.
I like things don't have to
be 100% Patton Oswald for me,
like kidney patents. Hilarious. I
love his writing. I love reading,
well sculpted bits,
but I also worry makes my innards fallout.
He's so funny.
Jim Breuer talking about his dad shitting
himself was apparently like one of the
all time funniest things that bill
bird ever seen. It's hysterical.
Yeah. Jim Norton was talking
about it too. He's like,
you can't believe how funny this bit
is. Yeah. It's like it just, it hurts.
How funny this bit is. Yeah.
He's such a good dude too.
He's another one was just such
a good dude. Just so nice.
You know,
and you're around that guy.
Like you watch them on stage
like it comes out of him.
Yeah, that he's like this a long island
guy. Yeah. He now it's all you can say.
I mean, think about Kevin James and Gary
Valentine and Ray Romano. All these,
all these long island guys, they just, it,
they don't get any better
than that is quality people.
There was a east side comedy club out
there that produced a lot of really good
talent. Yeah. Brian Regan. He
was Florida. But I think he,
I think when he came to New York
he was like Johnny Long Island.
Well that was,
I saw Jenny there.
I saw genuine side comedy club when
he was in his prime and I remember um,
one of the guys that works there was
talking about Jenny did a different hour
for each show Friday and Saturday.
He had four different hours all weekend.
They were all like,
we'd never seen anything like that.
There were all humbled to
like what in the fuck? Yeah.
Like there was a time in the late
eighties where Jenny was just on fire.
He was on fire and there was,
you know,
for whatever reason there was not as
much attention on him as some other guys
that had reached that same level
proficiency. Yeah. He got some attention.
Like you got some showtime specials
and stuff and he did really well.
He always did really well in the road,
but
I don't think he ever got the
recognition that he deserved.
No, he got that one shot. Platypus
man. And it was on like a second day.
It was on like WB or one of those
channels and it's, you know,
it's tough because the guy was like
chiseled out to be a standup comic.
He was a fucking Formula One standup
comedian, and I don't know how,
I don't remember the TV show,
but something tells me that maybe he
wasn't the greatest sitcom actor of all
time and that he probably would've been
better suited to be a late night talk
show host or something like that.
That was something that I think you
would have been better suited as being a
fucking awesome stand up comic. That's
what he was. Right. It's like musicians,
if you're a musician, they don't want
you to be a rockstar. They don't say,
or rather a, I'm a movie
star. They don't say, hey man,
you know the way you sing and dance,
you should stop doing that and just
start pretending like they don't.
They don't do that. But to a lot of
stand ups, especially in that era,
it was like he wanted to
get that Seinfeld money.
You want it to be Jerry Seinfeld,
do you want it to?
And there's this thing about
like a guy with a big sitcom,
whether it's a Tim Allen or anyone who
was like that and that day they got a
certain amount of prestige in Hollywood.
And when you're on the
outside your whole life,
which a lot of stand ups are the big
wish other than just actual success,
not just worrying about paying your bills,
the big wishes that you get inside.
They finally love you. They take him
in, they take you in and who was,
who was you trying to get to take you in
the Big Daddy? Hollywood, the Big Daddy.
Hollywood takes you into his
embrace, you know, and, and,
and turns out,
you know,
one of the great all time sitcoms with
you at the helm of it and you're the new
Jackie Gleason and you're getting out
there with your wife and you're waving to
the crowd every day and everybody loves
you and you get the book and juicy
charge. That's what they want, the inside
charge. Right? And he never got that.
Now,
I remember watching,
I was in Vegas and I saw him out on the
strip with a camera before there were
selfies taking a selfie of himself in
front of a big marquee that had his name
on it, but it was like a second tier
hotel and I was just like, oh man.
Wow, wow. And then you know,
from what I understand and you know,
it absolutely breaks my heart that he
took his own life because I think comics
are very vulnerable. I know I am. I get
very, very effected by, I wish I wasn't,
but I still like if I'm not getting the
money that I want or I'm not working a
club that I used to or whatever, it
can fucking really eat me up, you know?
Because it's so personal. I'm the product.
It's not, I'm not selling paper water.
It's me. If you're rejecting
an offer for me, it's me and,
and things go up and things go down.
But he was at a point where for the
first time, this is what I understand,
his date book was not fold up filled
up for the year by like February and it
always had been and that dude was doing
50 to a hundred corporate dates a year
at 25 grand a pop.
And those were drying up and he couldn't
handle it because it felt like so much
of who he was was wrapped up in his
value as a comedian. And as it's,
and I'm not saying it was eroding,
but in his mind it wasn't going in the
right direction. It was going forward.
It wasn't going out anymore.
This was it. He passed this peak
and he was in his forties
that what it was pool
and he, he was, his girlfriend
went inside to make breakfast.
They get out of bed and he just went in
the bathroom and shot himself and didn't
kill himself either. Oh, is that
right? No, he was still alive. Oh yeah.
They to take him to the hospital. He
died in the hospital and the whole thing.
Yeah.
It's beyond fucked man.
But so strange how you like
a guy like Robin Williams,
you know, you would look at in
sort of the same way like this,
but him even more so because
he's so loved, so loved,
but he wasn't on the inside anymore,
wasn't on the inside anymore and things
were starting to slip away as far as
like financial opportunities. He did
that sick call and that didn't work out.
The movies that were interesting to him,
we're all like independent movies,
barely paid anything, you
know, and the big roles,
they just don't happen that often.
Take them while they can.
But he had like a lot of overhead.
But apparently when he died he still
had a fuck load of money. Oh Shit. Yes.
Families fighting over right now.
I knew his agent and uh,
he wasn't broke by any
stretch of the imagination.
Like people would like to
say that, you know, like, oh,
the guy had just run
dry. Like, no, he hadn't.
He needed to have a picture
for a good four or five movies.
He had to be worth $100 million.
Well,
he definitely had made a lot of money.
How much it kept.
You know when you're balling like that,
buying this,
he had to like a $30 million ranch
somewhere like northern California,
some insane 60 acre fucking thing.
Yeah.
One of the things he was trying
to get rid of before he died, he,
and I think there's a lot
of jewelry I remember there,
take it to that liquidating his estate.
There was a lot like,
I think he bought his wife
a shitload of jewelry.
That's interesting to see at alimony
to pay more than once or twice.
Yeah, twice. That's why his nanny,
he went after that nanny pussy.
Oh that's a trap.
That's a trap because she's always
around, man. She's always around younger.
She's a better version of
your wife. Essentially. She
takes care of your cat. Yes.
Go with your kids
and at some point she was getting dressed
and he walked in at some point and
then you think in your head when,
I also think that for a lot of comics,
a lot of guys who like genuinely need
love and acceptance and approval for a lot
of these guys and shit never turns off.
Nope. It's on all the time and it's,
it becomes like a demon that
needs to be fed. All right.
And when you're in a relationship and
things get bored and everything gets
stagnant,
you take each other for granted.
They're not having it and not having
it. They got to keep moving. Yeah.
They've got to keep
moving to the next charge.
So got to get the next dangerous
relationship. The next wild Ra. Yup.
That's why drugs are involved
in a lot quick charge.
Divorce was a flaming lunatic
with riding his bike.
That dude would go out and ride a hundred
miles on his bike every day. Really?
Yeah. He was fucking psychotic
about riding spike. Hmm.
Cause cause he'd stopped
doing all the drugs.
Oh yeah. That makes
sense. That makes sense.
Because you definitely get high from
running and you definitely get high from
any kind of like extreme cardio. Like
then you get that endorphin high, right?
Yeah. They talk about that being really
similar to the high that you get from
marijuana with some people because
apparently it's cannabinoids.
Cannabinoids get,
they get activated by a you were
you doing cardio or doing jogging?
It's like a very similar thing.
That's why they call it runner's high.
Well I know guys that get high like on
their way to the gym. Do you ever do that?
Oh yeah. It's a good
match. Dare you ask me.
He asked me the different way. Do you ever
go to the gym when you're not high? No.
Shit really get high all the time.
Especially before I lift weights.
What do I want to be sober? How does
it affect your work? Gets better.
I get more into it. Yeah. Yeah. I feel
my muscles better. I feel like my tissue,
I feel things moving.
I think that one of the things that pot
does that is a really underappreciated
is it heightened sensitivity,
not just your sensitivity,
like physical sensitivity, like sexual
sensitivity. It definitely does that,
but also like your sensitivity
to people's feelings,
sensitivity to your own feelings and
your sensitivity to like lifting things
when you lift things and,
and I'm not talking about getting
obliterated where you forget where you put
your keys. I'm like, God, where's my car?
Oh my God, how did I get here? Oh my God,
I can't even remember walking in the door,
man.
I'm talking about just a little bit high.
Just we know you're a little nervous,
but you know what you're doing. You know?
And when you lift weights like that,
I feel like I'm more in tune with all
the different fibers of my muscle.
I'm more in tune with my balance.
I'm more in tune with where the,
where the weight's going.
It just feels more natural to me.
I'm more in tune with my body moving
as one unit. It just, I feel like
we're focusing on the muscles that
you're using and not the other ones.
Well,
focusing also on the,
the entire body is a balanced thing
as opposed to just like if I'm lifting
something, my arm, just thinking
about my arm when I'm high,
I'm thinking about wearing
my legs are positioned,
how my gripping the ground with my toes.
Am I engaging my back and my this,
my posture. Right. You know,
you just get real sensitive to all
the different movements of the body.
And in Jujitsu it's legendary.
Like very,
very few of these, uh, especially like,
like a lot of the Brazilian guys,
they came over and this,
one of the things that American guys were
shocked at how many Brazilian guys got
high before they did Jujitsu.
Apparently super,
super common even back in the day.
And nowadays it's a big part of Jujitsu.
Marijuana in Jujitsu go hand in. I didn't
know that. It's a huge part of Jujitsu.
It's not everybody and there's some
vehemently anti pot people. And uh,
that was,
uh,
one the issues that a lot of the Gracies
had with Eddie Bravo because Eddie
Bravo is like, he's not just pro
pot. He's like an evangelist. I mean,
he's a guy who got me smoking pot and
he's like, he's not just saying, hey,
it's not bad for you. He's
saying it's amazing for you,
like you need to try this.
And uh, but those punnets fit, that's
physical as well as mental funk.
Yeah, it's, it's, you have
a heightened sensitivity.
I think you have a heightened sensitivity.
And you also can get into a zone,
like part of Jujitsu is
about getting into a zone.
You've got to get into like what's called
a flow state and a lot of that comes
from doing Jujitsu enough to
where it becomes second nature,
like move to become second nature.
Like as if you make a mistake and you
put your hand in a certain position,
the guy doesn't have to
think, okay, his arms here,
that means I can shift my hips and throw
my way across his face. It just happens.
It happens before you even think about it.
You make that mistake and he's got it.
Like as you're making the mistake,
he's real.
He's like literally a half of a second
behind you every step of the way,
capturing all of your mistakes,
anticipating them and capturing them and
that happens in this weird flow state
and it happens better for me
at least when I'm high and see,
I can sense a difference
between boxing and you get to,
it's like in boxing you could last a
round or two as an unequal opponent,
but in Jujitsu they're going to find the
weakness and exploit it pretty quickly.
Yeah. You, if you're athletic and fast,
you can do surprisingly well in a boxing,
right? Surprisingly well. Yeah. If,
especially if you have advantages,
physical advantages like if
you have a really good athlete,
so he could took a like an
Oto Sinco that Chad Oto,
Oto Cinco guy like super
athlete fast as fuck, you know,
and he knows how to throw punches a
little bit. You know what I'm saying?
If you pay a cocky as hell,
cocky and just super athletes so fast,
if you put that guy,
give him a little bit of time to train
and you put them there with like a
journeymen amateur boxer,
not an amateur boxer that
like wins world championships,
but a guy who's had a few
amateur fights under his belt,
chill Cinco might fuck that dude up.
You know what I mean?
But just based on his
own physical advantages.
But if you put Ochocinco in ag and put
him on the ground with any Brazilian
Jujitsu, black belt, he's
going to get fucked up.
Immediate hundred percent he's going to
get wrapped up and here he is right here
working out. I mean the dude is just,
Oh damn. Actually he's got hands.
Did some working on a boxing gym. Yeah,
I'll do it. He can throw some punches.
He's very fast. Yes, that he would
fuck up a lot of people. He really,
his cockiness is a big part of it too.
We'll also be able to stand in
your shoes and face a guy for sure,
but also physical ability.
Like he obviously has the ability
to throw very fast punches there.
He'd be dangerous to anybody.
But Godfrey,
the John Jacques Machado is one hand,
one of his hands is a thumb. Okay.
If John Jacques Machado got ahold of the
shadow Sanko he's going to sleep. Yeah,
100% of the time.
Every single time.
Every single time that they clinch up.
I mean if they're striking evolve,
it can be very differently. If it was, if
was, if he didn't want grapple with them,
that guy is probably
so strong and so fast.
If he knew a few take down defenses
and knew how to stuff, some of that,
it would take like a really good wrestler
to bring him to the ground. But if uh,
a Brazilian Jiu Jitsu
blackbelt got ahold of him,
he's going to get tapped every time.
It's just a different thing.
It's not completely
dependent on athleticism.
Whereas like fighting is a
lot of athleticism. Movement
is a lot of athleticism.
There's some guys that you see,
they fight in the UFC and even though
they're doing well, it's like, you know,
they're headed towards a cliff.
Like you,
there's a certain aspect they're
missing in their movement.
There's a certain amount of speed.
They're missing certain amount of
violence that they just can't, they just,
they just can't put out,
they can't do it the way other guys can.
And there's some guys that just
like natural from the jump,
it can do it way better than
you. And a lot of ways. Yeah.
And those guys were always going
to be champions. There's, there's,
this is like this champion body and his
champion mindset and they vary, you know,
the varies by looks.
And some of them,
some of them might actually look like
Chubby, but it's not about what they look,
it's about what they can do with that
body. And some people just don't have it.
They just don't have,
well yeah, because it's an
eight. I mean it's, it's the
innate sport. It's survival.
You know, it's before, before
there were weapons and there was,
there was basically Jujitsu. There
was guys that were just, you know,
mixed martial arts. That was, that was
survival and there was no training for it.
Well, there was some training for a long
time and they've been training things
thousands. And I'm talking about caveman
man. Okay man, fuck yeah. I think the,
there's, there's like images on the walls
and pyramids of some sort of grappling,
like people who have been trying to figure
out what's the best way to get people
to the ground and beat the fuck out
of me for a long time. But it's just,
you know, it's until recently they
didn't really have it down. Right.
They didn't really know what they were
doing until the last hundred years or so.
Right. And the last 20 has been
more, there's more, more evolution.
The last 20 years in martial
arts in the last 20,000 yeah.
As soon as they figured out mixed
martial arts, UFC came along,
people started figuring out what
works and what doesn't work.
And you realize like there's a lot of,
there's a lot of shit that people
have been doing for a long time.
It's just nonsense.
Yeah.
Well, it all said, Yah. Physical training
is so different. People, you know,
understanding the way muscles work and
you know what kind of aerobic exercise is
best with,
you know?
Yeah.
I mean I don't know it look at me,
what do I know?
I get on a fucking elliptical machine
for a half hour and watch CNN and then I,
I live in,
I knew that nothing I do about maybe
seven or eight sets of stuff and I'm gone.
I see Callen come in,
he works out in my gym,
Callin comes in and he does this 25 minute
workout that it looks like he's in a
fist fight for 25 minutes in the gym.
He's working hard. Oh yeah. Really?
He works with Guy Lou,
this trainer
and Lou just pushes them
through and he's just like,
it's this total like
crossfit kind of thing.
Raise up doing crunches on and then he's
pushups and fucking crazy like kettle
bells and, and then he's just like
Superbad like the what the fuck was that?
Cause it's the only 25
minutes and he looks great.
You see that guy's body at his age now?
Seriously,
cock is delicious. It's not
delicious. But you know,
you've been staring at the balls.
Offsets the luck real close.
He um, he works out with
that box and burn place too.
So one of those cardio bus since he moved.
Yeah.
He's not in my gym as much as he moved.
He used to be on the west side West, so,
so he does boxing training.
Well that's where he was.
He was doing it down in Santa Monica
with Wayne McCullough. Call Yammer.
World champion, right? Yeah. He teaches
people how to box on there. Wow. Yeah.
But Brian was getting hit in the head for
awhile. I had to talk to him about it.
I'm like, why? He's sparring with
people. It's getting whacked in the head.
We went to Germany and impulsive,
ridiculous person.
Maybe she shouldn't be getting punched
by random 20 year olds. Protect it.
You got left asked you if you want
to spar. It's just saying, okay,
he's sparring with people.
Like, whoa. Yeah. Easy boating.
Yeah. That's not necessary.
Yeah. That's not good for you. He spar
though. You just sparked Jujitsu Jitsu,
sparring. It's different because you're
not getting hit in the head, right?
You could do it.
Look,
you could spark as long as you spar with
someone you trust and you're going to
get hit a few times, but it's not a few
times you really have to worry about.
It's the accumulation of many,
many gym wars.
It really winds up fucking
guys up. Right. That's um,
it's more common than you think
you ever grappled with Joey Diaz.
No one Joey on top. You,
you've got a stream that man,
if you set up a match with you and
Joey Diaz just to see it physically,
what did we know? What if
he dies? What's going to do?
Went away to go, imagine you trying
to give a eulogy at the funeral,
but he was so mad at me. Sorry.
Rogue and you fucking Ozil.
I would just let them tapping. You
couldn't tell. That's the thing.
You'd have to kill him.
Kill Joey Diaz. He'd be,
if he got you inside control a guarantee
you Joey knows how to hold his weight
down.
He's learned from Hagen Machado and
Machado is a legit world championship
caliber black belt, and he's teaching
Joey Real Jujitsu. Joey's 300 pounds.
If he gets on top of you and get site
control, good luck getting out of there.
You think he could hold you? I don't
know. I wouldn't want to find out.
I wouldn't want them. On top of
that should be what the video is.
He starts on top of you.
It's whether or not you can get away from
Joey Diaz that that would get about a
million downloads. Well,
I don't want to do it.
I'll help. I'm scared. I'll go into
there with you. We can both fit.
I'll bring a knife together. We might
not get out. You know, it will be like,
we'll be like those two guys at that
prison upstate New York who got the power
tools to escape. What happened?
You didn't hear about that. Oh,
this is the greatest
fucking story of the year.
Two dudes in a maximum security prison
in upstate New York. 3000 inmates.
These dudes got through fucking inch
thick steel walls with power tools.
They'd stolen from the prison,
went down into the piping,
like classic old school, like
Birdman, Clint Eastwood movie.
And they went into the sewer pipes and
they came up through a manhole cover on
the other side. They've been missing
since Friday night. Oh my God.
Five days they've been gone.
They have no fucking idea where they are.
So they're out in the wild. They were
out in the wild and they, they escaped.
He escaped at night and they didn't find
him until the morning. That's amazing.
And they left a little post it
note, uh, saying see you later.
A little Chinese guy smiling.
Watch.
I don't know. I think it was
racist. Whoa. Well it said,
see you raider didn't really
go to that store. I need to
see more JV. Don't go turn
away. Go Up to the top. Like,
when is it, when is it loud enough
that you can use fucking power tools?
Power tools in a ruse.
Oh Wow.
What is, uh, what did,
uh, what was the ruse?
They left a stuffed up pillows
with a Hoodie. I mean the, the,
the classic stuff. Bed for bed
check. What did these guys do?
Murder one murder to a cop.
Oh God.
They're looking for them in the wilderness
and rural communities of northern New
York. Right? Duping wow. It's, it's like
right out of a four in Canada, they had a,
they had a dummy fashion as sweatshirts
using power tools to drill out of their
cells.
The Clinton correctional facility,
the men made their getaway late Friday
or early Saturday emerging on the other
side of the prisons, 30 foot
tall walls. Wow. How good.
Must've fell to get out.
How good must that have felt?
Just troll through that hole.
That's the seat
that, that raising Arizona
moment where your birth memory,
that moment where John Goodman comes
out of the earth and it's muddy and it's
like he's being
born.
I wonder how the fuck they could get,
get away with this. Is there a way
to get away with it? Ultimately,
in this day and age, I mean,
this is a crazy day and age.
Everyone's got a credit card, you
know, it's hard to just have cash.
Well also, you know, they're going to put
their, their faces out on digital media.
They would see their faces.
Hmm.
Uh,
and the other crazy thing is their
cells were next to each other.
So not only did they tunnel out,
they tunneled in between their two cells.
Dude, there's a, Oh wow, that's
crazy. Employee question.
Yeah. This guy was supposed to maybe
pick them up and then he bailed.
He was going to pick
them up on the outside,
but he went to the hospital
instead and I don't know.
Yeah,
I hate cnn.com cause he was launch a
video on it. I don't want the video. Yeah.
Let me read. I can still
read investigators.
Think a woman who worked with Richard,
Matt and David Sweat at the Clinton
correctional facility plan to pick up the
convicted killers after the escape,
but changed her mind at the last minute.
So she worked there. She went to a
hospital this weekend because a panicked,
oh yeah,
there's a little stress.
Stress. Wow. You managing the stress of
helping murderers get out of the cage.
So what was going on?
Let me see what she looked like because
somebody must've been given her some
Dick. Oh, ah. Prison
guards are really high.
Right to at Jamie. Yeah, that's
exactly what was happening.
Someone who was slinging some Dick
our way. I would if I was in prison.
Yeah. It looks in, first of all,
that is gold in prison. That woman,
I mean it's,
it's hard to get any love at all.
It doesn't matter if
she's a little overweight,
she's kind to you and she's female.
You'd be super psyched.
I'm trying to think how low the
bar could go if I was in prison.
It guy really low. Small Guy, Asian.
Whatever you want.
I'm going to go Asian on this one.
Look at her poor bitch.
Double Chin classes.
Enormous. Probably food addict.
Can't see she, she was in love.
She said poop thrown at her for the
last 20 years. What's good? Yeah. Right.
What's going on now, man?
What's going on with her cheese?
She must've confessed. Right? The trouble
is that these guy, one was a cop killer.
So any her helping them in any
way. She's gotta be, she's,
she's walking by inside.
She's fucked. Yeah. Well not
only she walking dead inside,
she's going to jail. Well,
we don't know what she did.
She probably made a deal. She made a
deal, but she didn't do it out of it.
But it doesn't matter. She cries because
she knew that these guys were escaping.
Right. These guys are free. So if these
guys, these free men look at the creeps,
look at him. Quavers they look
really creepy. They do. Well,
they're real murderers. Yeah.
Look at them. If you, um,
okay.
If you just think about running into them,
I mean if you're,
if you're someone who runs it to them
and then you get kidnapped or you get
killed because they're trying to
get a car or something like that,
that woman is almost directly responsible
for that she could have prevented it.
Well, and they're going to kill people
because, uh, there is no going back.
There's no going back.
They'll be in solitary for the
rest of their lives no matter what.
Slane deputies, brother. I
just hope he doesn't come back.
Wow.
Ooh. Yeah. Cause there's a party
you that, I hate to say this,
that pulls for them just
because it's so fucking crazy.
But then you get to remind yourself
that they're pieces of shit. Exactly.
You got to remind yourself like what
if that was your brother they shot and
killed, right? Yeah.
But it is easy in because
of all the movies.
You see that to come up with a plan.
Yeah.
Well people have these fucking cells
and they're in them for 20 hours a day.
You have time to think.
It's all you're thinking about.
Whereas the guards are thinking
about a thousand things.
They think they've got everything covered.
But you start putting data together.
Like I know that the guard is at this
spot at two o'clock at two 15 he goes down
usually to take a piss.
You know when you have these ideas in
your head of how this is going to plan out
and when you see a path,
you see a path and you've been studying
it for years and years and years.
He just run for it.
Cause run for some weird path.
Okay, I've got a son. I get it. I,
cause I know when I was 1314
years old and I was grounded.
I was fucking out of there. I had my
window, I was on the second story,
but over a sheer drop.
And there was a ledge outside my window
that was about two feet long at a 45
degree angle with the old shingles on it.
And I used to have to go out my window
and Shimmy, holding the doorframe,
holding in the window,
frames of all the other windows,
all the way across to this side of the
house where I could jump down. And uh,
I used to go out every night and I
climbed back in again off a ladder that I
kick over and they never caught me until
one night I came home and I was drunk
as shit. And uh, and my father, I
remember my father threw a beaten on me.
So I went upstairs and I was like,
fuck this.
So I opened up the window and
I guess I was like, you know,
going loud because I was so mad.
And so I all sudden I looked down in the
back yard and there's my mother and my
father. My father goes,
Craig, get off the roof.
You're drunk and I shot like a squirrel
over the top of the roof and onto the
front yard. Dove down, ran down the
hill, ran away for like three days.
Oh my God, you rebel.
And uh, did you really?
Three days and the whole
time I was gone I was like,
they don't fucking know where I am. I'm
a, I met my best friend's house and he's,
he's got a,
he lives in like this tenement and as
he's got a single mom and meanwhile she
had called them [inaudible].
What do you think a parent's not going
to call another parent when their kid is
staying at their house? I'd literally
didn't occur to me that they were onto me.
So did they let you stay there for a
few days? A cool off. Was that the idea?
They wanted nothing to do with
it. They just, they just let,
and I remember coming
home after three days,
I cooled down and I remember walking
home was a Sunday night and the sun had
gone down and I walked through my
backyard and I looked in the living room
window and my mom was up one light on
reading the newspaper and I just remember
looking at it thinking she was just so
all alone and it struck me for the first
time like, wow, she really,
she, she missed me, you know,
like I was missed because in my mind
the whole time it was like fuck them.
They were the enemy,
they don't care about me.
And then I came in the house and I was
expecting to get another beating and
instead she just like very cold. He was
like, go to your room. And I was like,
how you think this fucking thanks.
Started before
ladder again.
Very good climate. See my stroll
routine again. I gave it a shot. Right.
Get 'em done.
Probably 14
there's a lot of people who've left, ran
away from home around that age. Yeah.
That's the age, right? Between 14 and 17
yeah. My kids 14 now I'm
riding it real, real gentle,
little loose on the reins.
Give him some space. Yeah.
You can't just tough though
to then pull it with you.
CanNot the be upset with you? No,
I'm trying to stay, first of all,
it's a very existential thing that
my son is bigger than me. He's a,
he's an athlete. He's in better
shape. He's stronger. He's bigger.
So you can kick your ass. No, he
can't kick my ass now. You sure? No.
What if he learns he's a black
belt in taekwondo? I told you that.
How come you don't think
you can kick your ass?
Because I think you're
intimidated by your dad.
I don't think that you can
let yourself beat up your dad.
That's my only weapon right now.
I can fuck my dad up. Yeah,
but back then too. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah.
When I was does that my fucking car
find out I had a problem with it before.
Yeah. So how come you never
did? I didn't want to,
but I'm, I wasn't really
physically threatened. Right.
You know, checking shit.
My,
uh,
my car went off out here for like an hour
and one night I didn't know it was my
car. Who's fucking cars going off like
that? Somebody had hit me. Oh fuck.
Really Dude.
When you have a parking lot with a
bunch of people out in the parking lot,
they're always bumping into,
people are half paying attention and
they're texting, they're parking,
doing a really shitty job of
it pulling out. Like I just,
I saw somebody hit somebody the other day,
um,
with one of these big ass Ford
pickup trucks, big long bed
pickup, chug and axles
just backs up. Come on.
Well, I mean, I don't
know where this guy lived,
but I remember watching
him back up going to,
you know how to drive that
fuck dog fucking dummy.
He just got way too good in that is a
big ass metal bumper and fucked up some
guys light.
Now I'm not a racist or
homophobic. Yeah, I am, but not,
I wouldn't call myself that,
but I got a problem with people in
cities that drive pickup trucks.
I find them as a people to be bad people.
I find them to be closed minded and a
overly aggressive shook night ran over
this people in a pickup truck. It's
all right. He was in a raptor Waze,
forward raptors and even a
good one. Right. How it is
probably the best one. Oh no shit. Yeah.
It's a pickup truck with like
a real off road suspension.
Like you could drive the people
take those things out into the
sure they do. Yes. 14 people do.
Most people buy them and they never
leave the fucking pavement. That's,
but if you wanted to, those things
have a main road capabilities.
My neighbor has one. Well I think
about, Oh holy shit. That's the new one.
That's bad ass. Oh, there are
beasts. I want it's got that
plate in the front. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. It's a called again
with plate called splash guard.
I think it is.
But the thing is,
when I think about the apocalypse or
some type of gas attack that hits La,
one of those is these, well because
the roads are all going to be closed.
And when I was a kid,
we used to ride,
we serve ride motorcycles
underneath there were power lines.
It ran from New York City all the
way straight, straight up state.
And at any given point you
could get underneath those
power lines cause they had
a service road because they got a service,
the power lines.
So there's always a dirt path and it's
the greatest for motorcycle riding.
But I'm sure there's the same thing in La.
There's gotta be a way out
underneath those power lines. So if,
if the four or five is going
to be shutdown, 10 shutdown,
the only way out is going to be in a
truck like that. On a road like that,
there's gotta be ways that you could get
up to San Francisco without driving a
road. But I can't imagine them. Hmm. How
could you need some wire cutters? Will,
you'd have to go through,
you have definitely have wire cutters,
but you'd also have to go through
something. Some mountains and shit. Yeah,
like you're not going to get through
mountains and that thing right.
Then you would need one of those
even you wouldn't be able to do that.
I was thinking you need like one of
those jeeps that you can crawl with and
they'll rock crawling. You ever see people
do that shit? Right, but what about the,
what about that path that, what's her
name took in wild Reese Witherspoon.
I think that's real.
That's like saying the titanic
movie. Do you see that? Yeah.
That's not a sound real. Those,
those fake, the, she never,
all actors are all actors and actresses
and she walk. Yeah, but what do you think?
You can't take the truck or somebody
can walk. No, you can't. Oh yeah.
She jumped through some river beds.
Get through those trees, right truck.
Stop down all the trees and make an
obvious path and then to follow you.
Maybe you need a motorcycle.
I won't even work.
You couldn't dig a motorcycle through the
mountains now? No. You'd get to the top,
it fall, landed on you break your leg,
you die up there wolves and eat, you know,
fuck man,
that's no way to go.
I'll take the gas attack
back in La based their Sushi.
It's hard to figure out whether you would
want to die instantly in apocalypse or
whether you'd want to be the next
group of survivors that eventually five
generations later became the new
civilization because the first couple of
civilization it's going to be fucking
Genghis Khan Times. It'll be mad max.
It'll be, yeah, it'll be the worst,
the worst aspects of the walking dead.
They will be only raped.
There will be no consensual sex.
It's going to be like it is in certain
parts of like the Congo. Right, right.
You know places right now that
are really remote and fucked up.
That's why the whole world would
be like, yeah, and but there,
there might be some fun to
surviving and then dying,
like being a part of the wave of people
that are staggering around with their
eyes burning, but like you're one of
the ones that that is healthy compared
to them.
For a while.
So you kind of feel like there's this
ultimate reality show happening and you're
right.
You're one of the finalists here.
One of them. You are the survivor.
Congratulations, Greg. The
rest of the world is dead.
He had all the fish and coconut,
and just as you're rounding up all
the coconuts, all of a sudden you go,
no,
there's to Jay, you settled a
slightly better immune system.
You lasted a few extra days,
but I got the go, go nuts.
It's why that show last was always so
intriguing because everybody wondered
like, what would you do if you were
removed from the rest of civilization?
How would you survive?
What would life be like?
I know when they kind of nailed
it because they humanized it.
They didn't make every like
planet of the apes and all that.
Everybody's very stoic
and they've got the same,
that was a bunch of real
people reacting in real ways.
Yeah. Some more weeks I'm
were strong Samad character,
the fat Guy Somehow to
rise to the occasion. Yeah.
Some gave their life and sacrifice.
Some became leaders automatically. Yeah.
Yeah. That was, uh,
in a lot of ways it explored like one of
the main thoughts that people have when
they look at the, the, the fragile nature
of society. Like if it falls apart,
how would I do what would happen?
What would it be like? Yeah.
And that's what a show like that
covers Gilligan's island, you know,
although no one fucked ginger or Maryanne,
there's no,
no one fucked at all.
If you want to talk about like one of
the most unrealistic shows of all time
Gilligan's island had to be
because there was no sex,
there was no sex,
and yet how old are their basic human
needs are pretty well met because the
professor built these kick ass huts,
anal lagoons, stuffed with fish.
It was like they were in Eden,
so they had plenty.
It's not like they didn't have time to
hit on ginger. No. Make her a fucking,
make her a necklace out of some coral
and they were always trying to leave
and go back to civilization that all the
people in civilization would
watch that show going, dude,
you're in paradise. Yeah,
you're this girl. Can't do any better
than you cause there's no one else. Right.
You're trapped with like the hottest
woman on the world. The movie star,
the professor and Marianne.
Hey Ron Galella again.
And the pride for professor was in a bad
looking dude with a handsome bastards
hush up with either one of those
little cow fucking she wasn't.
She was an animal. Good Lord. God.
Look how fucked hot shit. Damn. She
wears skimpy outfits too, didn't she?
Of course she did.
I love how they pretended she had
like Cheetah skin outfits on. Yeah.
Where are you killing the Cheetah?
Did you skin that?
Cido like how the fuck did you make that
day? Really Escalate Marianne now too.
But they kept her who? She
was at hot Gotti. Fuck, I
thought Marianne was hot. Er.
I agree. She's more my tech.
Yeah, I mean the, the ginger.
She just seemed like she a lot of work.
Look how hot Marianne is to say
that Maryann was not the hot one.
What the fuck man? Yeah.
Really. How's that Pos Marianne
is hot as fuck dude. Yeah,
she is. She just slightly different.
Just ginger's trying too hard, right.
Marianne's got a straw hat on
Marianne is she's the girl in
the barn given out hand job.
No, no, no. You're Mary or
Bro. What the, yeah, no,
you're married Mrs Howl.
Yeah.
You got to bring her a lot of jewelry,
but you married her look. Oh, look at the,
you look at Maryanne's body in that house.
Holy Shit.
She had that seventies body
to a little wider in the hips.
Little thick at the top of the leg,
but the flat ass Peli with
the recess belly button.
Oh my God.
And he shouts of the feet Kyla.
That old school foot fetish.
How long they weren't high
heeled shoes on a rowboat. Wow.
What a weird, weird, weird show. Yeah.
What did your dynamic as
far as only three women,
three women and two of them were
young and stupid. Hot with no suitors,
no obvious suitor.
There wasn't like a football player
that was also on this three hour tour.
Who crashed there with them?
Some big brawny Dick slinging
savage from the Iowa corn fields
doing dead lifts with palm trees and Shit.
Trying to stay fit on the island.
No and no, there's no one, there was
Gilligan who's ambiguously sexual. Yeah.
Like you didn't know he was a boy child.
He might've been gay.
He did no masturbation.
His shirt was always clean.
It was red and always like
absolutely squeaky clean. Yeah.
And he always had that stupid hat on.
And then there was the professor and then
there was the skipper who is this slob
who just stayed fat despite the fact that,
you know, there's no, there's no pasta,
there's no bread up there. Where was he
getting all the sugar from? Anywhere.
Ever lost any weight.
That's incredible that he could keep the
weight on because they also had to be
rounding shit up.
They had to be active just to survive.
They all had tailored clothes.
Look at the professors. Sure.
[inaudible] was a j crew catalog.
His shirt never showed any
sign whatsoever of fatigue.
Like he's out there with one fucking
shirt in the middle of the jungle. Yeah,
it looks amazing.
Right?
You like the greatest shirt advertisement
of all time iron. It's iron as fuck.
Look at recipe, the chorus and
look at the, look at skipper.
He's get that stupid hat on.
Yeah,
and makes sure he wears a skipper
hack so everybody knows his rank
and that's the crazy thing. And Mr.
Howell, who, who has, he's got milk,
he's a millionaire.
Which by the way,
think back to that actually
meant something back then,
having $1 million meant you had trunks
and trunks of clothes and jewelry and and
he basically did nothing. He never did
any lifting. He never did any work. You,
I wouldn't be like, motherfucker,
money doesn't mean anything.
This island anymore.
Go rake up the beach. You got to
wonder how did he get that money?
Did he win the lottery? Was he given
that money? Family, it's family money.
Who was the black and white Gal in the
middle there? Right there. Who's that?
That's Tina Louise.
Like how's that possible?
Wow,
this is what she looks like now.
Whoa. Why did that sound happen at the
exact same time he clicked on that.
How rude. Go to view image. Blow that
bitch up. This is what she looks like now.
Well, she's gotta be like
quite old now, right?
Oh. Time. You Bitch.
You Bitch.
How dare you?
2015 they get the Ted style.
Go,
go big on that view image.
Age restricted. Whoa. Oh,
that is a goddamn shame.
Time is a ruthless motherfucker. It's
not like she avoided the knife either.
I hope they made the money. So sometimes
you find out. No, they did. They did not.
They did not.
That was a long time ago.
Probably signing pictures at
conventions and shit. Wow.
Because none of them worked again.
Poor guy.
I don't remember seeing any of them
in anything else. No. I'm Gilligan.
He would do like these, uh,
I would love both shins.
When we would do these fan experiences.
They'd paid to take photos
with them and she had a family.
But I don't know if he did that.
But a lot of like a lot of stars wound up
doing that. They do autograph signings.
They get, what's the range
of conversations you have
at that here? You'd be,
you'd be Gilligan.
I'll be a fan that's coming up.
People in the line and then like
every conversation is rushed, right?
Because there's a bunch of people behind
you. Yeah. Hey, I love you as Gilligan.
Thank you. Thank you. Move
along please. Was there,
did you guys really go to
an island for that? Um, I'm
sorry sir. If you want to, uh,
answer questions across more.
And what about afterwards?
You Ginger, Marianne hire.
Just one more thing. We just
do. You can't say that. Why not?
Because we're at a signing. He just
broke my Maryanne. Maryanne, thank you.
Here's $20 for the bad conversation.
Hasn't had that same conversation over
and over and over for five hours a day.
And that's the only way
you can pay your rent.
But isn't that better than working at
like a Shitty job? Malleable. Mine,
definitely. So it's just, it
just sucks in perspective.
Like if you just saw what she looked like,
look, yeah, that's a lady in her seven.
Right?
But if you saw what she looked like when
she was in her twenties and then saw
what she looked like in her seventies,
that's when it hurts her feelings.
It's tough on women because with Mel, how
she still hot, she said it looks good.
She looks good. Marianne was dawn. Well,
Marianne was clearly the one cause she's
still very pretty at 74 years old. Yep.
Yeah. Yeah. Tina the was a
lot of makeup and fashion.
Riyadh was just pure.
There's your answer. Yeah.
Boy. See, let's see a picture
of, um, Killigan today.
Much more forgiving.
I bet you think so.
Gilligan from Gilligan's island now.
Okay.
It was still kept it. The professor
looks up top. Do you have a duty still?
This other professor was like, Michael
Kanban is about a hundred years old.
Who's that? Who's that
guy ran the pressures.
No, fuck. Yes it is. Oh my God.
He lost all the weight except the nose
didn't lose the way every other part of
him did. Is that a real wow,
that's interesting, man.
Yeah.
It's interesting when someone would get
on a show like that and p a huge star,
like I dream of Jeannie.
Yeah. Remember that?
What a piece of ass she was hot as fuck.
But she would go from that,
from that and like not do
much after that. Right, right.
And the guy who played her
boyfriend on it, didn't they?
Sweary Hagman they swapped them out.
Did they? Yeah. Larry Hagman. No,
they had a different one. Was it?
I dream of Jeannie are bewitched.
I'm being way with two different guys.
Yeah, they were just crazy. Yeah.
There were a couple shows that swapped
the guy out, the main guy. Right.
And be wished they swapped.
The main guy,
somebody held up on his contract and
they went, really? I'll see Adrian Chang,
you pal. Larry Hagman one. I'll
do a lot of shit. Hell yeah.
He did a million different things.
So that's not a good example.
But I was thinking of troop actually
a few. Richard Dawson went on.
Yeah. Oh, F troop. A lot of those
guys, we, a lot of those guys went on.
I was confusing bewitched
with a juror and Jeanie. Yeah,
but they were both super hot
women. Oh my God. To be which lady?
What is the name? Tabitha Stevens.
Is that what it was? Bewitched.
That's also the name of a porn star. Yeah,
I think tabulated Weinstein. He wished,
what was her name? Yeah, that's right.
She was a really hot when she was hot
as shit. Oh, there's another picture.
I just love that you could go in and
pitch a g is a genie that this dude locks
in a bottle, but B, which was a witch,
she would do that thing where there
are no [inaudible]. Right, right.
Remember she would do things with their
nose and then she's doing really nice,
which, and she could do anything,
but he wouldn't let her.
It was a total fucking
male chauvinist pig shell.
It was all about a woman's ability to do
things and a man holding her back and I
dream of Jeannie was the same
thing. Yeah. He wouldn't let her,
he locked her up layer.
Do reach your powers.
I wonder which one stole the
money or stole the idea from who?
Because it's kind of the same story
in a way. Yeah. Very archetype.
Archetypal. Right. The typical
right. Archetypical was story.
His story is very similar. Yeah, but wait,
go back to that picture for a second.
Controlling man, look at, look at him.
He's got his hand over her mouth and he's
pointing at her face in an aggressive,
abusive way,
and she looks scared.
And that was on a sitcom
before that's fucked up you,
while she could turn him into a fucking
broom, right? She'd do whatever she wants.
Turn his dick into Jello. But she
loved him. He knew, he knew. She met,
no matter they were assholes.
He was an asshole.
And Larry Hagman was such a Douche on
that show. All you could think was like,
dude, why don't you just get a nice bed
and breakfast with this bitch up in Santa
Barbara? She said, go into the greatest
pussy of all time. Go fuck the gene. You,
what's wrong with you,
dude? Enjoy the Hamsini,
the bottomless bucket of blow job that
she's going to offer you and magic.
She loves you. And she loved him
and he wasn't interested. Nope.
She lived in a bottle.
Fucking speciesist asshole.
Which one was the original
Darren? Oh my God. Wait a minute.
There's two different ones. Okay. That's
the difference between bewitched and I.
Dream of Jeannie. They're both
Hondas. Janie was beyond hot.
She was in hottest fall. I
know, but Jeanie was crazy hot.
If there's any upper left
hand corner, you're right.
Look at that right there. Bam.
There's your answer right there. Yeah.
Barbara Eden was just stunning. Yeah,
they're both hot as fuck. What are you
talking about? Either one of them B,
which was pretty, she's a 10 Jeannie
was just a fucking splurge monkey.
She was looking at her with that outfit
to look at that belly of the top man.
Yeah. Oh, you could kid. You look
at that. Oh, didn't like the face.
Yeah, the old as fuck. But look at
her body man. Once she got older,
body was tremendous.
That's nice. Look at her.
What are you going to do?
You get them.
You get to marry a woman
that stays in shape.
That's what they make shows
like this anymore. Why do
you think that is? You know,
they did third rock from the sun and that
had a nice big run and then a fantasy
sitcoms kind of went
array array after that.
Is it a rare rye?
I always fucked that up.
I meant away and I fucked up I that array.
So then you saved me by saying
awry like niche or niche,
I guess you could say both. Yeah.
Someone said you're not saying it right.
And then I said you sure?
And then I looked it up and you
apparently you could say both ways,
niche or niche, right? So there
is no like, is that correct?
I don't think there's a correct way.
Right.
You're neesh neesh sounds better though.
Sounds like you're sophisticated.
They're sort of Porsche, Porsche, Porsche
cars. I own one. I have to say it right.
Oh, you can all, you should only be able
to say that way if you have one. Yeah.
Well No, you should say correctly no
matter what. But my friend Maurice Smith,
he was the one, the first one to correct
me. I go, yeah, that's a nice poor.
She was a Porsche Porsche. Say
Porsche. That's what it's called. Okay.
It's like a white trash thing, you
know. What about Jaguar? Jaguar?
Is it Jaguar to say John, you all, well
it's not owned by England people anymore.
We say Jaguar or kind of a
cat. Is it? It's a Jaguar.
Is that of a cat on the bumper?
Yeah, but it's not jack. It's Jaguar.
Hi. Some American say Jay. You are and it
really is Douche flag number one. Yeah,
you are. Yeah. The Jaguar in Afghanistan,
one might say Jaguar. Yeah.
Have you talked to county?
Literally almost just said,
I bet Calabasas Jaguar is so good
at pronouncing things correctly.
Afghanistan,
but he grew up in a million different
countries all over the [inaudible].
You are in Chile and Chile.
I actually say chilay cause I was there
once and it really is like ugly American
Chile. Chile. Yeah. It's really ugly
American here for Chile. Chile. Hey,
get a case of deer. Well there's certain
countries where we just named them.
We don't like your name. We call
you something different. Yeah,
I like to Deutschland. Germany. We
like Germany better. Yeah. Other Lens?
Nope. Holland. Sorry. Yeah. What's the,
what's the really, there's one really, oh,
Japan. They don't call Japan. They
didn't, it was Ni Pong. Yeah. Yeah.
We call it Japan. Like you got your
own name now, bitch. We're like,
we're like the Ellis island of countries.
We tell you what your new name is.
These guys that escaped. What part of
the they're, they're an upstate New York.
And are they near the woods? Is
that, what would their near him?
This is a good time to do.
It's the northeast corner of New York,
so they're pretty near Canada. Oh.
So they're just going to go see,
see the fucking note.
Have a nice day.
Racist picture of a Chinese guy
with buck teeth and slanted eyes.
Do you think they're trying to say
that they're going to China? Ah,
it is an interesting choice and it looks
like the circle was made with like a
protractor. Those lines are dead
straight. That wasn't an afterthought.
Yeah. That's a beautiful line. That's
right. Yeah. The triangles perfect too.
Yeah.
That's weird.
Have a nice day and it looks like it's
held on with a magnet or something. Yup.
That's exactly what is. Hold
on one. That's hilarious.
They are hilarious murderers who carved
into steel pipes and how the fuck did
they know where that steel pipe went to?
Well, that's where there must have been
people on the inside security thing.
Again, if you think being
a fucking prisoner is bad,
being a guard they say
might even be worse.
So now you're going to work every
day having shit thrown at you,
worried about being killed,
breaking up fights, total monotony,
and then and then on top of it
so you get a chance to maybe,
maybe these guys are siphoning money to
you from some relatives on the outside
or a gang on the outside and all of
a sudden you've got an extra 20 grand
because you got the schematics of the
pipes from the office when the boss wasn't
looking.
You're going to do it.
Look at this fucking what
they were in jail for.
Sweat was serving a life sentence for
shooting the sheriff's Deputy 15 times in
2002 Matt was in prison
for the kidnapping,
murder and dismemberment of a man
who had fired him from his job.
At a food warehouse. Well, I was a
food warehouse. That's a tough one.
It's a good gig. Get it.
You've got to protect.
You got to kill and
dismember for that one. Whoa.
So these are sick psychopathic dude's.
Yeah,
his tattoos on his back and
say Mexico forever. Well,
I guess we know headed.
It's a ruse though. That's the route
they went to Canada. Canada, forever.
That's his, that's going to
be as new tattoo. Well, you
could live in Mexico. Um,
you're not going to survive in Canada
once it gets cold. You know, if you,
if you escape into the border and
you go deep, deep, deep into Mexico,
you might conceivably reach some place
where people never question who you are
and you eat some existence as a
laborer or something like that.
And they're not on the same websites. If
the Canadians are on the lookout. I mean,
that whole, if you live within 500 miles
of that escape, you're on high alert. Oh,
and you're looking at the pictures and
if a couple of dudes wandered to town
that nobody knows it's over. Yeah. Yeah.
No doubt about it. No doubt about it.
And anybody that's in the
woods that lives out there,
you're going to be on high guard
watching out for your supplies. You know,
maybe having a gun when
you ask people out guns,
you kind of really worried about being
in Canada too because that's where people
try to go when they escape.
Yeah.
You know like you're escaping
from literal imprisonment,
like someone locking you in a cage like
a rat and you get out of that cage just
as fucking, I've got to
make this work. I'm free.
And how much food do you have
and how much time do you have?
And how much of this plan have you
really set into motion? 50% of it.
100% where's the girl? The
girl's not here. Fuck, she's
calm down. Once you realize, what are we
going to do? What are we going to be in?
A chubby person didn't get in her fucking
minivan and pick it up at the forest.
Right? I'm going to rip the fucking
whiskers out of her chin. And then,
and then you got to know how much we
push forward and how much do we just stay
and hide. It's like a fine line,
right? It's like a chess match.
You got to make every right move.
You know what you do?
The guy who killed and dismembered the
probably kills the other guy and starts
eating them. Right? That's the move. Yeah,
but like you could only keep them for a
few days. It's warm up there. Right now.
It's June. Now. That is one of the
worst times to try to keep meat.
Now you get two dinners in a branch
out of them. That's about it.
You got to have to cut
away the rotten spots.
Get to carry a ham hock with you
and dig into it. Uh, when you're,
when you're on the first spot,
you eat the well on an animal.
You'd take the Strip of meat
that protects the spine.
It's called the back strap
on each side of the spine.
There's a delicious slice of meat.
The loins,
the backstraps in the loins lines is
the ass. The loins is all the back.
It's all the inside,
like with lines,
the spine and then you go to
the hams as the back back legs.
Hmm. And then the shoulders,
organs, the organs.
It depends on the animal. It probably
don't want to eat a bear liver,
but you can eat their heart. If he cooked
it well enough, eat a pig's heart. It,
Cook it well enough and you have to cook
it to 160 degrees though. All right.
Different animals have different
diets and they have different diets.
They have different parasites. Some
animals like pigs, especially wild pigs,
bears and things along coastlines.
Got to worry about tricking osis but
if you eat, eat, eat, eat a human,
assuming you go for like the
buttocks first you could.
That's what they did in that movie was
that movie with those guys crashed in the
Andes and froze and they had to eat each
other's. They the eight ass was alive.
Yeah.
They dug,
dug out this guy to pass frozen ass
with a spoon as Nina because they were
desperado. Ooh, that's when she gets ugly.
That's when shit gets ugly. My
friend. The guys not in shape either.
It's much easier to eat some flabby ass.
Yeah.
That's why I don't eat that up. Excuse
me. That's why I don't eat that.
Why goop beef? I feel like I'm eating
like the Chris Christie of cows.
Just some sloppy fuck that's barely alive.
It's just like gelatinous
shitty cow of marbled up.
And some people love it though.
Ooh,
I've heard people talk about that kind
of beef like it's the most delicious beef
they've ever had in their
life. Well that's what
[inaudible] is. It's a lazy cow,
right? You just string them
up and he doesn't move worse.
It's a baby too young. They
take a young calf and the, uh,
sometimes they just leave them in a pen,
a very small pen where they can't move.
Sometimes they feed him milk and sometimes
they actually bind them so that they
can't move. Well, is that that stuff,
why you beef from Japan Wagyu?
How you say it?
Why do you, will you set the stuff
that's super expensive? Oh yeah.
It's really expensive.
They feed them Saki and beer.
That what you're looking at is
a dying animal. Essentially.
A cow is in no way or shape supposed
to have that amount of fat content.
It just is not.
It's not supposed to be built like that.
It's supposed to be all red lean tissue.
Now compare that pull up grass fed beef
now completely pure grass fed beef is
how beef is supposed to look
and it's not nearly as lean,
like go to like a cut of meat. See
if they have any, that's just a,
that's a Ribeye, which is a pretty
like, yeah, go to like a New York strip.
Like what you get is okay. The like
scroll down like right there, right there.
I click on that tenderloin, right. They're
not to the right. Yeah. There you go.
Look at that. That's what it's
supposed to look like. Right.
With what you're seeing
there is a darker red,
very little fat content cause
blood flowed through there. Well,
the only reason why there's fat in those
animals because they're eating these
really extremely high crawl
at high calorie grains and
grains that their body is
not naturally designed to process. He,
I think Alfalfa is a big, they feed them
Alfalfa's not bad because it's
just a plant, but the corn, um,
apparently that they're,
uh,
they're eating is what really
gets them nice and marbled. Yeah.
It's the corn that gets him going that,
that fig grain.
I think Alfalfa is like more of, you
know, it's more of like a Veggie,
a more of like a regular
green plant. Right? Yeah.
It's not a starchier as thick as a
now it's so it's like a wheat grass.
Who the fuck he eats Alfalfa though.
You know what I mean? Like Alfalfa
sprouts. I like Alfalfa sprouts. I salad.
I wouldn't need it straight on, but thrown
it on a salad. It gives it like that,
uh, that Crisp Enos. Yeah. It's
got that weird texture, right?
Yeah. I love salad bars, man. It's, it's,
so you just said good salad bar where you
just throw on some iceberg and some of
those mini tiny, uh, corn
ears and some mushrooms. Those
are always pickled, right?
A kind of understand a little bit pickled.
And then you throw on shit like
cranberry juice and sunflower seeds.
Radishes, radishes. Fuck. Yeah, man.
And you have good radishes are for you.
I had a really good science
teacher in junior high.
I went to a shitty junior high school
in Jamaica Plain Massachusetts.
It was not good at all. It was
a, it was real sketchy area.
There was kids that were like 17 years
old that were in the seventh grade when I
was there. Like they were, you know, it
was a lot of fuck ups, a lot of idiots.
And I was there for seventh
and eighth grade. And um,
but I had a really good science teacher.
This guy was just a super dedicated
to being a science teacher.
He was, um, just who would ask
you questions and he would,
he would make it. He was the first guy
that made me think about space. Uh,
but he had radishes and
he grew rashes in his, uh,
in his garden and he would bring them
in and we'd have radishes at lunch and
explained that when
you're eating a radish,
there's so few calories in it'll radish
that you can eat the entire radish,
the amount of calories it takes you to
process to chew and process and then
digest that radish is the same amount is
in the rafters, right? It's like, it's a,
it's a wash like you eat, if you want to
lose wages, eat radishes, like your, your,
your Bot. And it was like, whoa.
That doesn't even make sense that you
could eat a radish and the amount it takes
to process it made me think
about that. But he, um,
he also made me think about
space. He said, if you want to,
you want to really make your head hurt.
And this was, you know, seventh grade.
Like how old are you when you were
in seventh grade? Nine, 13, 13.
Something like that. Young.
Yeah. 12, 12. He said,
you,
you have to think about the
fact that space goes on forever.
There's no end to it. Like just if
that doesn't make your head hurt,
then you're not thinking
about it hard enough.
And I remember him saying that like that
space goes on forever and nobody had
ever said that to me before.
Like everybody was always do it.
We talk about space as big.
It's base,
the big bang happened x amount of billion
years ago and they say it in a way
that it's, it's very factual and
actual and it's all, you know,
you're recognized and
memorize that number,
13.9 billion or whatever the fuck it is.
But when someone says it doesn't end,
it never ends.
Like you just keep going and going
and going and going and going forever.
He's like, do you understand what
forever? It just keeps going.
Like there's not a time when it runs
out of space. It just keeps going.
That's always my argument against
because I believe in some type of God and
that's always my argument to people that
absolutely negate any type of a higher
power is,
is infinity.
You explain to me even that fucking
glimmer hope of solving infinity to me.
And I'll give up the whole concept of God.
Why does,
why do they have to be mutually exclusive?
Why do you have to be able
to solve infinity? Like what,
what is it about infinity that
means to you that there's a god?
Well,
cause it's a concept.
It's a concept and a
reality at the same time.
It's like the idea that there's a physical
thing that can't be quantified in any
way means that there has to be some kind
of a force that I wouldn't even call it
a force.
That there is a,
there's a paradigm that's
controlled and consistent
and that that's what God is.
There's some,
there's some type of a
template to all of it.
I've thought about this a lot.
I'm sure you have to.
One of the things that I think about
what to think about the universe and like
the idea of the Big Bang and uh,
I've,
I've read since some
interesting quantum arguments.
Some were really weird theories about
the birth and death of the universe.
But one of the big ones to me is like,
why does it have to have a birth
and a death? Why are we so,
it's why are we so convinced that
the universe had to have a beginning?
Like why could not it have
always been there? I mean,
isn't that an option too when you're
talking about something is absolutely
ridiculous as infinity? Why is it so
ridiculous that it's been here forever?
Like why does it have to
have a beginning and an end?
And that fucks with my own version of
reality and a lot of ways because my own
version of reality is birth and death
is what I'm experiencing. It's what,
uh,
you know,
like we have these biological limitations
and we impose those sometimes on other
things. That's what it is. Star,
the birth of the solar system
has only been alive for, oh, what
our lives are a narrative.
It's like,
you know how you'd say every script can
be broken down to a beginning, middle,
and an end. And the many of the
plot structures are similar.
Like that whole like Joseph Campbell
thing and uh, and you know, the whole,
that whole idea of beginning and an end
is so rooted in our lifetime that we
can't yeah,
we can't see past it.
Yeah.
It becomes something that we look for in
other things instead of considering the
possibility that there might not be a
beginning or it might not actually be a
beginning, it might be one of an
infinite number of beginnings.
Like there's been a lot of people
that have theorize the possibility
that the expansion of the universe,
that it will reach some point and then
ultimately collapsed back down to that
infinite point again and then
start all over again. And there's,
there's some resistance to that because
they can kind of through some sort of
radio telescope can pick up the actual
emissions that they believe are the
signature of the big bang. It's very,
very, very, very, very complicated stuff.
You tried to summarize it as a standup
comedian and a podcast with two dudes
that may or may not have smoke
weed. It gets real sketchy, but,
but even if there was nothing
until 14 billion years ago,
isn't that like the ultimate
fucking magic trick?
Like if forget about a god, all
right, even if there is no god,
if there is or there isn't,
forget about the concept of it.
How about the idea that everything that
you see in the sky came from something
that was smaller than the head of a pin
and it did so an impossibly long time
ago in an instant.
So this is the theory,
the eve from the people that tell you
that there's no evidence that there's a
god and that Jesus sounds like a
horse shit story. You know, that was
forget Jesus has gone by
traders written on animal
skins at one point in time.
What everybody agrees is that the
universe was smaller than the head of it.
Right? And then when it did explode
and created all of this matter, yeah,
it did it in a way that was all consistent
with the same laws of physics and
gravity, which they still
can't. They still can't figure
out gravity. You know, why?
How it can exist in,
in,
I think it's quantum physics and
gravity still have not been, uh, uh,
brought together in any way.
Right?
They try again, I'm an
idiot, so don't listen to me.
But I think dark matter is a one
of the, uh, the main, the, the,
the,
think about all the matter that they're
aware of in the universe and they think
about the effects of gravity and the
computations don't work unless they add in
this idea of dark matter.
Right?
The idea of dark matter being that the
universe consists of a bunch of different
things and a lot of it, the great
majority of which we can't even see
because there's an inverse forever
for every particle that's positive,
there has to be one that's,
that's neutral.
And for every piece of light there has
to be dark. And for every, you know,
everything has an opposite in
the universe to balance it.
And that's what dark matter
is. It's the, it's the,
I don't know what I'm talking about,
but just the whole idea behind infinity
and black holes and galaxies and every
black hole or every galaxy has a black
hole at the center of it. And there's,
but there was just an article.
That's what I'm trying to spew is that
I just read an article about this black
matter thing and how it is,
it is all that there is a balance to
everything in the universe, which is,
it makes sense. And that goes to
the spirituality and you know,
Buddhism and you know,
there's everything opposites,
the Yin and the Yang Yang in the Yang,
the Rockaways,
and a lot of ways, you know,
that's what they said, Greg,
you get out of life what you
put in. Whoa. They were right.
Fuck. There was this time to reap.
And there was a time to sell to.
That's so true. And when you only reap
and you never sowed, what'd he get?
Lottery winners. They
go broke quick. Right?
Kids who when their
money from inheritances,
people that are squabbling over the
hundreds of millions of dollars at Robin
Williams left behind.
They're raping the reaping and so maybe
some of the wives probably did a little
sewing. They probably had to,
was a lot of work. He had this,
you know,
the thing is about inheriting a hundreds
of millions of dollars is the fucking
backstabbing that it takes. The lawyering
up, the energy, the negative creativity.
I mean Jesus Christ. You know what
carved me out five mil. I'm God.
You guys have fun with 100 million.
Yeah, I know she's going to kill you.
I know some brothers that are
going to war right now over there.
Mom Railey suing each other.
Shit,
trying to get a piece of that past
sun. Suddenly I had my moms, Bro,
let me get a taste.
Let me wet my big.
Just the idea that you know you're going
to compete with your brother or sister
for what's left of your mother.
It's just whoa,
because it all comes down to what you
think is right. That's what the gay,
you always put under the guise
of what's fair and what's just,
it's like nothing's fair adjusts. He
didn't earn the fucking money. Yeah.
It's just when you starting
to think about a loved one,
that way you start to think about
them as a payday. Yeah. You know,
and then their postmortem is once
they're in the ground. Okay, okay, okay.
How are we going to do this?
Because we're talking about a substantial
amount of money here and the family's
family businesses business.
You start getting really creepy
pissy when that parent gets old.
The older they get, the more that
shit becomes real. And how many,
how many brothers or sisters spent extra
time with the dying mom trying to get a
little, yeah, the mom was at
one point in time, you know,
I've been thinking about this. Well,
it's just not right that Johnny gets,
which you get, he doesn't even help
me. Johnny's a piece of Shit, Ma.
I know he was over at your favorite that
I don't resent you for that because he
was on the football team
and I was doing drugs. Okay.
But Johnny was always a piece of shit.
And who's here now, mom? I mean, what?
Your mom rubbing your feet,
rubbing you stinky feet with your fucking
dried out toenails all curled up in a
straws. I would like to end on something
better. We only have two minutes.
Listen to on a positive image.
Positive image is he takes that
money from his mom and he goes,
does Iowasca come become centered?
And you know what I heard they're doing,
they're doing um,
ketamine for people with depression.
What's ketamine?
Ketamine is a cat tranquilizer and
extremely psychedelic hallucinogen cat
tranquilizer
that they're treating people with
depression for. Yeah, I'll talk,
I'll talk to you about it
after this podcast is over.
Cause one of our friends is doing
it. I'll try it. Yeah. I would.
This one a why I brought it up.
I had to remember,
apparently it's having an
amazing effect. No friend. Wow.
It's a psychedelic,
it's like doing an asset.
See I need the kind of thing where,
you know,
are she fears got me convinced that
if I take mushrooms in a certain,
in a certain way that it can change.
Like not ongoing.
I don't have to keep taking it.
You can just take it.
And it can change your perspective.
Oh, definitely. Well,
for a period of time you take enough and
you go into it with the right attitude,
with the right people to write, really
want to be by herself. You know, Shit.
People will help a little if
they're the right people, but you,
you're counting on a lot of
people to keep it together. Right.
I think that a lot of those things,
sometimes the journey,
the best path is just get by yourself.
I like to do it. Get by herself.
Like Mckenna used to say,
silent darkness is the best place to
take them alone in silent darkness,
darkness.
It's,
I think it's one of the reasons why I like
the sensory deprivation tanks so much.
It's because you're forced to
not bounce off of each other,
but just forced to find what it is about
yourself that you're trying to work on,
what it is about yourself.
We're out of time. That's it.
That's the music we worked. I put Simmons.
Greg fits. What's the Fitstar radio
radio at Fitz,
doug.com follow me at Greg Fitz Shell.
All right you folks. We'll be
back soon. Much love. Bye Bye.
Jamie.
Had to hit the news.
Okay.
Yeah.